well seeing how last year everyone
seemed to enjoy seeing me get tortured
with the Disney sequels this year I'm
gonna do something kind of similar at
least I think it's similar in that I
haven't seen any of the subject matter
I'm gonna review this month I'm talking
about the Disney Channel original movies
now seeing how these start in 1997 I'm
not gonna lie they were a little past my
time so I didn't grow up with any of
these why are they worth talking about
them well because the Disney Channel
original movies got so popular that
almost helped define a whole generation
okay not too fine but it was a big part
of it it was too many kids what's a
Ninja Turtles was to me or he-man or
transformers or any of these other silly
things that a lot of people my
generation grew up with yeah they were
ridiculous but they also left an impact
for some reason well all through the
month of December I'm gonna take a look
at these films and tried to figure out
why they were so popular if they deserve
to be so popular and if they hold up as
an adult or where they only met for kids
and even if so were they really any good
for kids now if you take a look you
quickly realize there are a ton of these
movies that go way beyond how many days
there are in December so I'm only gonna
try and do the most popular ones and if
there were ever any sequels to did they
deserve the attention the popularity
well there's only one way to find out I
have no idea if I'm in for something
great or something terrible or both I'm
curious to see what a generation under
me grew up with and if it actually holds
up at all some of these are even movies
based on shows I'll get an idea what
kind of shows kids were watching - am I
in for a wild adventure or nothing but
pain there's only one way to find out
this is Disney summer the Disney Channel
original movies let's do this
so the very first filmed ever premiere
was in 1997 called under wraps I'll
admit I don't remember people really
talking about this but it is the very
first one so I think it figures to talk
about now from the story under wraps
ounds like the most phoned in Disney
Channel movie you can imagine three
quirky friends get together and break
into an old creepy house they discover a
mummy's tomb and inside it a mummy and
the mummy comes alive and starts running
through suburbia not knowing where to go
or what to do wouldn't you know it a
little friendship starts up but some
evil mobsters want them for themselves
and yet this sounds really friggin
stupid but surprisingly for such a lame
and overdone setup this can really be
funny creative imaginative and even have
Cavett arc sense of humor yeah no joke
don't believe me just look at how it
opens a family is arguing around a
dinner table the little boy calls his
sister a cow it always starts off so to
life Lea mean-spirited the father goes
to do the dishes but then a knife falls
in the garbage disposal spinning around
when a monster breaks through the window
grabs his head and stabs it on the
spinning knife in the garbage disposal
holy shit I can't believe this is a
Disney Channel original movie starting
off this way now of course it goes the
direction you think it's going it's not
really happening it's a movie they're
watching but even in the movie the whole
entire theater goes red like the gore
happens they're just not showing it and
that's a really creative way to kill
somebody
this bill starts off with already a
really original way of killing somebody
off but it doesn't just stop there the
kids in this movie are super cynical the
lines they say to each other are almost
like Simpson lines even though they
can't swear or do anything that wrong
there is kind of this edge to them that
reminds me a little bit of Monster Squad
it's hard to explain is kind of like
this natural mean-spiritedness that most
kids have at that age but for some
reason aren't really shown on screen
that much kids do throw insults at each
other and they tried to see if they can
one-up one another they talked about
sleeping in the nude they want to go
inside this house where somebody died
just because they can they discover
later that there's a key to get into the
house and when they asked why they
didn't use it they're like what's the
fun in that breaking is much more cool
it's that bizarre kind of kid logic I
strangely enough kind of remember at
that age this is line where this one boy
asked what to sell him to Semien and the
girl says it means no chicks he says he
could never do that and she says trust
me you'll get used to it okay it's not
shocking but it's just that little extra
that separates it from a generic Disney
film and on top of that all the
characters are strange like really weird
odd people there's a guy who owns the
weirdest bookstore that's covered in
skulls and gore and he answers the door
by pretending he has a knife stabbed in
his back and he falls to the ground
how would that keep any customers that
would scare everybody away but that's
more important to him than actually
selling anything even the characters
that the fast-food joints are kind of
weird and odd they all have distinct
characters and allowed them just focus
on hurting this poor mummy every other
second he's either being smacked or
pulled or even burned look at this his
nipples are on fire and this is that a
hospital - everything is just out to
hurt those poor guy speaking of which
this is the same guy who is from Coach
and gargoyles and he actually has two
roles than this he plays the mummy who
sadly doesn't have much talking or
expression but he still does okay and
they also place the guy who's dating the
main kid's mom he doesn't like him very
much despite him being very nice and
yeah they're kind of doing like a
Captain Hook thing aren't they were both
the father or father to be and
supernatural character kind of represent
that fear of what's coming forward but
then you see he gets used to the monster
as he'll get used to the dead and yeah
you know what this actually kind of
works it's been done but I think a lot
of the stuff in this movies been done
but they kind of playfully acknowledge
it even when it's really stupid at the
end where they have to fight off the
phony gangsters how do they do it they
pretend like their eyes are gushing out
of their heads and then they knock the
person out and tie them up with
intestines I love this kind of stuff you
would never see this in a Disney movie
this kind of just barely g-rated humour
tickles me in just the right way it's
not overly dark and aggressive to a
point where it becomes awkward but it's
just enough the downside is the second
half does slowed down a little bit and
some of the laughs go a little quiet but
I thought the whole thing was going to
be like that for
good I don't know two-thirds of the
movie I was surprisingly kind of
enjoying it okay not loving it but there
was some last year in there I don't know
I'm not gonna act like this is anything
great but for a little Disney Channel
movie I thought it actually had more to
it than it needed if you're looking for
that little kid Halloween movie that
goes a little further than it needs to
with some memorable characters weird
scenes and surprisingly funny lines I
say this is a tree we're checking out in
the same way a kind of self-aware
b-movie is worth checking out take a
look for yourself and see if it's worth
getting wrapped up in
[Music]
from one Halloween movie with
under-wraps to another one with
Halloween town but sadly unlike under
rats this is pretty much exactly what I
thought I was gonna get with a cheap
lame Disney Channel movie
I guess they made a couple sequels to
this but god help me if I can figure out
why this is stupid this is the kind of
movie you would see a Mystery Science
Theater it's filled with hokey acting
lame effects and surprisingly not very
creative ideas that is to say the
initial setup is not that bad
three kids are forbidden to go out on
Halloween because the mother says they
can't but things start to turn around
when their grandmother played by the
late Debbie Reynolds literally flies in
and says that she needs the mother's
help the kids over here follow the
grandma and discover that she is in fact
a witch and they follow her on this
magic bus to Halloweentown and if you're
anything like me you're thinking
halloween town is gonna be something
like halloween town the one from
Nightmare Before Christmas weird
buildings dark creepy odd everything a
little askew but nope it's a bright
cheerful place that just has a bunch of
people in Halloween masks oh I mean uh
ghouls and goblins ooh but Halloween
town is in trouble because this evil bad
guy who kind of looks like a mix between
the Grim Reaper and Jim Carrey's Grinch
and acts about as subtle once Halloween
town to take over the land of the humans
so they don't have to live apart anymore
actually doesn't sound like that bad of
a plan I'm not sure why they're separate
anyway but nevertheless the grandma
tries to teach the kids how they can be
little witches and warlocks to come
together and stop his evil magic okay so
from a setup like this obviously story
is not gonna be a biggie this is some
excuse to have some really creative
images and ideas and characters and so
on and so forth and that's not for the
most part what we get here the writing's
not especially imaginative it just sort
of goes by the numbers Hey look a ghost
hey look a werewolf
the acting isn't necessarily all full
but it's just bad enough like the 13
year old is supposed to be odd and
strange and a bit of a weirdo seen is
how Marnie likes weird stuff so much
she's got the weird part down pat
Halloween is like made for okay look and
listen to this kid and tell me if you
would get that and how are we supposed
to grow up if we can explore the world
try new stuff and take some risks uh-huh
no Daria is a weird kid the Monster
Squad are weird kids you're like the
cheerleader from American Beauty trying
to be weird but doing a really bad job
at it because you're the everyday
average kid there's nothing odd about
you the brother is the typical geek with
all the analysis and book smarts theme
brings up at every single moment because
that's all he is
give me a good nature documentary any
day well that candy causes cavities and
gum disease
trees are important too you know
everyone's got their thermostats set to
68 degrees degrees science that's my
entire character never seen that before
and the smallest one is so bad they only
give her a sentence at a time he'll
sometimes just a word at a time
Ellie's pecan game I wish like the
turncoat frost it was a bad thing the
only one who's ever doing a good job is
Debbie Reynolds I don't know what it is
she acted like every single part she got
was the role she always wanted to play
she just puts everything into it and
she's 100% believable even in such a
silly idea languages they're mean and
scary oh no no no no sweetheart I mean
they're just like everyone else and
we're kinds and remaining that's thank
yous they're magic aside from that I'll
give some credit to some of the
creativity in the makeup I mean don't
get me wrong
they're obviously masts they don't look
real but they're kind of like the Evil
Dead movies you know they're fake but
they're very creatively fake some of
them have really cool designs and I
specially love this skeleton taxi driver
Oh first time it's a few kids look at
this thing
look how expressive it is it would have
been so easy just to have a skeleton in
a cab hat and just have the mouth move
up and down but look at this the
eyebrows have a low motion the mouth is
moving left and right as well as up and
down it's actually a really good effect
but then they ruin it with this line fry
animatronic Disneyland's full of stuff
like that yeah did I ruin the illusion
that's like someone coming out to the
Muppet Show saying yeah you're probably
all puppets most likely from the Jim
Henson studio
well douchebag
once in a while there's a joke that gets
a little bit of a laugh like I enjoy how
the witches microwave has boil and
bubble and toil and so forth there's a
fun little segment where the kids have
to get ingredients for a spell like pair
of a werewolf Fang of a vampire ants
what of a ghost
how do they do that in this world by
going to a barbershop a dentist and a
gym of course meetings are probably the
film's best line ghosts are dead why
would they worry about fitness but aside
from that it's pretty empty I mean just
look at this place when I hear Halloween
town I want to see something dark and
creepy and whimsical not just any other
town with people wearing some masks it's
kind of like a mix between a bad
goosebumps episode and that really lame
babes in toyland starring Keanu Reeves
the few creative elements are nice but
it's not enough to cover up the
cheapness of both the writing and the
budget I suppose if you have like little
little kids this is fine or I don't know
maybe it did have more of an audience I
thought they made a ton of sequels but
when you hear halloween town and you
think of something more like what the
cover looks like as opposed to this
bright suburban sunny day then i say
this is a definite pass
[Music]
it's xenon girl of the 21st century and
if you think that doesn't date it take a
listen to this president
Chelsea Clinton yep that's the kind of
on the nose writing we're going to be
dealing with here
well okay looking at this maybe it's
supposed to be the late 21st century
that gives a bit of time twenty forty
nine yeah definitely optimism at the
height of foolishness but whatever it's
children's fiction what's the story well
Xena a tween each girl lives on a space
station and does all sorts of things
that girl that age usually does hang out
with her friends listen to bands get in
trouble all that stuff but when she sees
that the biggest funder of the space
station seems to be up to no good she
tries to call him out on it but nobody
believes her as punishment for her
actions she's grounded literally she's
grounded down to earth which she barely
remembers because she left when she was
in kindergarten as you'd imagine Earth
and the space station are very different
from one another and she has a hard time
fitting in her aunt Judy is a little odd
the clothes are all different people
talk different even the food and gravity
are off from what she's used to but
slowly over time she starts to make
friends and they start to realize maybe
all the things she was saying about the
Thunder was true as those evildoers
tried to track her down because she has
some sort of secret disc and ultimately
she ends up trying to save her space
station while also trying to get a dance
with her favorite boy band yeah it's
pretty silly it should probably imagine
there isn't really that much in this for
adults this is clearly made for a very
target audience of I don't know let's
say five to eleven year olds because of
this a lot of a storytelling acting is a
little over the top but I have to admit
when I was that age this is the kind of
acting and storytelling I liked
listening to it is exaggerated there are
a lot of catch phrases but the film does
try to contribute a few interesting
ideas and fun environments the space
station for example it's a really cool
design I just love looking at I love
these colors I love these setups okay it
looks a little cheap but it's almost
like being on Deep Space nine except
from the little kids point of view I
always thought that became a neat idea
but the nice thing is the fun stuff
doesn't stop when she leaves the space
station her interactions on earth are
actually kind of interesting because
she's not very familiar with it she
thinks everyone constantly has to dodge
tornadoes and earthquakes and sicknesses
and if someone grew up on a space
station that is probably what they would
assume they say that gravity on earth
compared to the space station is also 30
pounds heavier and they demonstrate this
very cleverly by just having your go on
this bridge that's at an angle and they
tilt the camera and that's a very simple
way of showing it but it's also really
effective
there's also fun contrast like even
though she constantly gets into trouble
and can do all these cool things on the
space station she's afraid of horses
she's known as a risk-taker back at home
but she's terrified of trying a burger
she even has good comebacks for these
stereotypical bullies seeing how people
on earth and Space Station is dressed
different this one girl goes up to her
and asked if she's gonna be in a freak
show or dressing up for Halloween
her response you win now lend me that
mask you're wearing and I'll have the
most hideous major costume ever oh I
love that you think she's gonna go
through the whole movie just with her
head down looking sad and stuff but no
the first insult she gets she throws it
right back I love that they played
around with that a little bit but on top
of that it has a clever way of
demonstrating a very familiar lesson it
is a fish out of water story and about
adapting but it's a kind of adapting
that a lot of kids that age can
understand it's moving from one location
to another where the clothes are
different and the language is different
and tiny things you took for granted can
suddenly get you in a lot of trouble but
by adding that extra element of having
it in the future and on a space station
it makes it a little bit more
interesting it's more fun than creative
even if sometimes the effects are pretty
laughably bad come on these were
embarrassing even by the standards back
to that but while the effects don't look
that great they do still take the time
to have a character be in a moment while
the characters don't look like they're
really there they feel like they're
really there the movie takes time to
just focus on their reaction and play
some nice music and feel the environment
and they get the same thing on earth to
where you can appreciate the ocean and
landscapes and such I think this movie
knows what's gonna be fun about it is
the environment and they let you as a
kid enjoy it is a cliched sure can the
characters get annoying sometimes
but a few imaginative ideas and visuals
mixed with even a few good performances
from the boyfriend in the end
give it a nice enough atmosphere where
if I was the appropriate age they were
aiming for
I would probably enjoy it not much in it
for adults but I don't really think it's
meant for adults it's meant for kids who
need to learn about being out of place
but also about accepting new ideas and
new environments then this does have
some imaginative ideas and environment
what's adults but fall asleep but I
think most kids would have a cheesy but
fun time
[Music]
[Applause]
where do I start with can of worms just
imagine you're channel surfing and
suddenly you come across this did he
read you your rights
explanation and if you those are just
the table scraps of insanity that this
special has to offer it's the craziest
goddamn thing I've ever seen I mean it's
absolutely ludicrous and don't I'm not
good and I don't even have the words for
it the story if you can call it that
centers around a kid named Michael just
listen to a couple seconds of him
thousands of spaceships bristling with
with force fields and weapons surrounded
the planet video motion that would be
doomed doomed yep
that's the kind of performance you gotta
put up with this whole film you see
Michael is a bit of a nerd so much so
that he believes he's from another
planet
yeah not make believes believes believes
he constantly tells stories to this
little kid and he acts like it's real he
tells himself that he can't be but he
can't help but shake the feeling that
maybe he is I'll put that on the back
burner for about 40 minutes yeah there's
no talk of aliens or anything like that
for 40 minutes in this hour and 20
minute movie instead we focus on how he
sucks at football yep the lead
cheerleader of course falls in love with
him and asks him to help her put
together all the decorations for the
Halloween dance he uses all his computer
skills and nerdy technology to make it a
big hit but the bully sabotage it
causing him to run out in a panic what
does he do he goes to his giant space
satellite you know like every kid has
and sends out a message to the universe
that he's being held there hostage and
wants to be taken to another galaxy
again like most kids would I fulfilled
life nullified by the
indigenous population of her lightning
strikes the satellite and he soon
forgets about it until a dog
voiced by malcolm mcdowell arrives
telling him that he's from a nonprofit
organization that wants to take him to a
world where he'll feel more comfortable
but wait it gets stranger soon other
aliens start to arrive for various
reasons one wants to make a lawsuit out
of him and sue the earth another wants
to sell the rights to his story to make
an intergalactic movie another wants to
be his agent
it just gets stranger and stranger but
then things get really out of hand when
one comes to kidnap him for a zoo
accidentally stealing his little friend
and they have to go in and save him
while also saving one of the aliens he
thought he was in the story he was
talking about in the beginning yeah it
looks like they're real how did he know
about him how does he know how to open
their cage and use some of their devices
it is never explained they never say
whether or not Michael is an alien or a
boy
they never explained how we got all this
information it just ends with him
petting now can McDonald dog behind the
ears so long yeah this is exactly as
goddamn insane as it sounds I guess from
the oddness of the story and kind of a
satirical edge you can maybe get a few
jokes out of it maybe there's some
possibilities for it it's just so damn
strange but no none of it goes together
the story is horrendous the writing is
ridiculous all the acting is
over-the-top none of it makes any
goddamn sense
the only thing kind of interesting about
it is the design of the aliens I mean I
had to give credit these are some pretty
bizarre out there puppets but aside from
that I have no idea what I just watched
this has got to be the friggin weirdest
thing Disney Channel has ever put on TV
and that's saying quite a bit even my
kid movie standards it's ridiculous the
first 40 minutes almost nothing happens
except you watch him get ready for this
dance and then the rest of it is all
this talk about lawsuits and signing
contracts and stuff that a lot of kids
probably wouldn't follow it and it's
it's just stupid
it's so stupid you just can't believe
what you're watching half the time
the only way I can think to describe it
is the Santa Claus vs. the Martians of
Disney Channel movies it's not just bad
it's laughably bad and I think even kids
that watch it wouldn't know how dumb it
is I guess on that level it's kind of
entertaining I mean how could anyone
predict where any of this was going to
go but if you want something that's
entertaining on say a kids level and
adults level a satirical level a
charming level or performances that
don't look like Walter Venezia doing
Zack Snyder then this probably isn't the
movie for you and if it is the movie for
you please kindly keep your distance
from me
[Music]
the thirteenth year I guess Disney
really had a thing about turning kids
and the merpeople didn't they well kind
of like Little Mermaid - this one is
kind of as least interesting as that one
was not to say it's awful it's just not
really anything which is a shame because
again I don't think this is that bad of
premise her mermaid is swimming with her
young baby but a man sees her in a boat
afraid for her son's safety she drops
him off and tries to distract the man
the boat only to have a couple one of
them played by Dave Coulier pick him up
take him to the police and when nobody
claims him they decide to adopt him
Thunder Mae mother surprisingly just
kind of stays away for 13 years until
suddenly the boy named Cody starts to
notice certain changes he's swimming
faster he's growing gills he has
electricity oh and he can stick to walls
um yeah and vampires Sparkle his parents
don't know what to make of it the doctor
just says it's puberty yeah second
opinion much only his nerdy best friend
can figure out what it is he's turning
into a merman how does he know because
his father is the one that saw his
mother years ago Oh small world first of
the stories just him coming to grips
with his powers trying to find his real
mother while also keeping his girlfriend
while not embarrassing himself while
also trying to make the swim team and
the championships
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah it's about as
generic as it gets
there's a ton of things that don't make
sense in this movie like I said before
the mother staying away for 13 years
come on
she couldn't flop on to the beach and
get someone's attention or something
just destroyed the mystery if your
freaking kid hill she distracts the man
in the boat by showing off what she is
and he's like oh my god I gotta prove
mermaids are real and everything what
she showed off to that guy why couldn't
she show off to other people keep it a
secret why is it even a secret why don't
you use your electric powers that you
suddenly have yeah I guess they kind of
make a connection to electric eels but
that doesn't explain why they can stick
to walls everyone is just a little off
to like this one team makes fun of him
because he always comes in second with
you he always comes in second that's
impressive
even the girlfriend for his birthday
just
gives a picture of herself that's
strangely narcissistic and then she just
closes her eyes waiting for a kiss
everything this movie is just a little
off there's another scene where his
hands are sticky and he's shaking them
off and then the mother just starts
doing it too and then the father comes
in and starts doing it with what's even
going on here this is some quirky
strange this is just strange strange
even Cody's performance is a little
strange I mean it's not laughably bad I
mean he's not over-the-top or too goofy
but maybe that's kind of the problem too
he doesn't really stand out he's just
kind of boring he's the every kid to a
fault you can't really imagine yourself
in his shoes because he doesn't have
much of a reaction I don't know if he
was written that way or directed that
way but it just doesn't come across as
anything the only thing I really took
out of this movie strangely enough is
the guy that sees the mermaid originally
you may recognize him from a few Sam
Raimi movies like a simple plan and even
though he always kind of plays this
southern redneck bumpkin he always does
this part really well to a point where
it's actually legitimately dramatic the
part where he's talking to his son about
what he believes and he can help it and
is he crazy looking for other people
crazier than him it's actually kind of
touching I always got a perk up every
time he's in a movie it's always
interesting but aside from that when
Dave Coulier is your next most credible
actor you kind of know you're not in a
good spot like I said I can't say this
movie is terrible it wasn't awful
watching it it's just kind of like
watching nothing it's really a shame not
only is this an interesting idea I mean
the ocean underwater fish life I mean
it's interesting but it's also unique
that took an idea that's usually meant
for girls you know mermaids are usually
girls it gave it a little bit of a spin
by making it a boy
you think these little touches would
help it stand out but it just kind of
gets lost in the mix I don't know if it
was just an uninteresting script or if
there wasn't time to direct it in an
interesting way or shoot it in an
interesting way but it's mostly just
forgettable aside from a few dedicated
fans it's unlikely this one's gonna stay
afloat for very long
[Music]
you
so when going over the list for this
year's Disney semver I knew I had to
drop one of these two movies to make
room smart house or princess protection
I use people on my facebook who grew up
with these movies which one they want to
see thinking they would say princess
protection because hey it's Disney and
princesses that's just kind of their
thing but overwhelmingly everyone said
smart house not just picking that one
but praising that one like it was
actually a legitimately good film so I
popped it in take a look and yeah it
actually kind of is I mean okay it's
corny has bad effects as clearly aiming
for kids but I found myself legitimately
entertained by what was going on and
even laughing quite a bit the story
centers around a family who big Shaq
just lost their mother recently the son
has put it upon himself to take care of
the household and is decided to enter a
contest to win a smart house a home
where everything is taken care of by
computer they of course win and find
that the house is actually quite perfect
apart from a glitch here or there it
actually seems to do everything for him
and seems quite pleasant but when those
glitches do happen they have to call the
inventor who it turns out is sparking a
bit of a romance with the dad the son
doesn't like this as he's still getting
over the loss of his mother so he
decides to program into the computer
named Pat but she should be more
motherly hoping the father won't see the
necessity of dating the computer not
only complies but over time it gets
obsessive it lets up all the motherly
things that mothers are supposed to do
and dozen times 10 she's strict but also
playful it forces good morals but
doesn't always practice them when
looking after her kids and yeah starts
to see the family as her family when
everybody realizes pet might be going
too far she suddenly turns herself into
human for a hologram projection that
decides it's too dangerous outside and
so she decides to hold the family
hostage it's as crazy as it sounds but
in all the best ways the writing in this
movie at least when it comes to the
dialogue it's not necessarily the best
but they got good actors and a good
director to really bring it to life they
can make unfunny line seemed
legitimately humorous and take non
emotional scenes and make them actually
kind of tearjerkers the family is not a
rotten family they don't just throw
insults at each other all the time like
on a sitcom they actually get along
pretty well and they're
and they have distinct identities and
again I think a lot of that comes from
the acting and the directing the Sun for
example in any other movie would be seen
as unrealistic or strange why he be
obsessing over keeping the house clean
and tidy and such but the movie and the
performances do a great job showing that
it really is because he can't fill the
void of his missing mother he sees that
when his father wants to date somebody
else its betraying his mother that's
some heavy material for a Disney film to
take on but by god they take it on and
they do it seriously
it isn't just the full house routine
where you know oh this is where you hear
the serious moment and you tune out and
they just say those catchphrases no they
really talk about it and you really
listen speak in a full house all of
these characters and jokes could so
easily fall into that category being too
corny and too nice but there is enough
conflict in their everyday lives and of
course with the computer and the missing
mother so it never really feels
ungenerous katey sagal as path is a
perfect choice every time she talks it's
funny it's a great evolution going from
that robotic voice that could be
hilariously obnoxious not to worry Nick
my database was prepared by a team of
nutritionists to a gradually changing
tone of her being this overly obsessed
even insane mother does it hurt like the
dickens baby nobody goes after my boy
and gets away unpunished and when she
finally takes on human form it's even
better look at that evil smile that's
both funny and terrifying it's
interesting that this movie was directed
by levar burton Geordi from Star Trek
this honestly makes too much sense now
we did he act on Star Trek but he
directed several episodes and if you
watch Star Trek you know that lathis
centers around sci-fi technology which
often ties in to the problems and
conflicts that are happening on the ship
say a family coming to grips with the
loss of a family member while the
technology in their lives has created a
conflict that ties into that struggle
this guy has had years of watching and
directing stories like this and he does
it wonderfully here the only problems I
really have our nitpicks
like there's a scene where Pat wants to
torment a bully in my opinion it could
have been a lot meaner and a lot funnier
there's also a scene where Peck is a
loving look to the boy at the end even
though it's clearly the
same look that was done before and was
meant to be evil that time little things
like that can kind of get in the way
along with some of the corny effects but
honestly the story the characters and
the acting really pull it through I feel
like everything that can and should be
done with a kids film about a smart
house is done in smart house it's a
movie kids can watch for the zany news
but adults can also get a few laughs and
even some dramatic moments out of it too
not a chore once but just done well
enough the best way to put it smart
house is a smart flick
[Music]
well seeing how I thought the first
scene on movie was charming enough I
expected the sequel or zzzquil huh
to at least be as good if not better as
it starts off it seems like it's gonna
be good
it has a particularly funny opening
where she sneaks into a control room and
finds what she thinks is a game of pong
not only is it funny that she's blown
away by a game like pong seeing how it's
so simple and they just don't have games
like that in the future buts maybe even
funnier when he find out the paddles are
actually the doors sucking stuff into
space even starting to get people
involved in there okay I thought we were
in some good hands but sadly that's
where the best stuff of the movie stops
you see another authority figure is
coming to the space station and again is
threatening to close it down to make
things worse
his daughter is the girl that she didn't
get along with in the first movie and
Xenon's been assigned to show her around
and do whatever she wants even cut her
food but Zenon can't think too much
about that if she's putting a part of a
ship to mostly just keep her out of
trouble it's a section that tries to
track any signals for alien life when to
know it as soon as Zenon takes over she
hears a signal for alien life but for
some reason nobody believes her she said
she heard the sound like a zum-zum and
what they don't have a recording of it
they can't go back they can't hear it
again this is the technologically
advanced future naturally this happens a
couple times and every single time she's
the only one in the room and she has to
tell everybody it happened again with
nobody believing her so she once again
travels back to earth again spending the
majority of the film down there
reuniting with her and her best friend
and of course the girl she doesn't like
who sneaks off with her for some reason
and they tried to find the rock star
from the end of the first film because
they think that the message is actually
his song and the aliens want to talk to
him do you find this ridiculous yet
don't get me wrong
the firs enon was a silly film but it
had a little bit of a charm and
creativity to it this is just on repeat
except there's little charming about it
most of the characters aren't even that
likable I hate how nobody believes her I
hate this girl that's supposed to be
annoying but instead of coming off as
funny annoying she's just annoying
annoying I hate the fact that she breaks
up with the boyfriend at the beginning
of the film
and is treated like no big deal no
actually it is a big deal it kind of
affects her but not enough to pay him to
have them come back in the movie the
musician gets annoying the ant gets
annoying the parents get annoying the
general is annoying
everything just has a slow unimaginative
feel to it even the aliens at the end
when you finally see them just kind of
look like rejects from the abyss at
times it's even hard to follow there's a
lot of talk about what the aliens want
and how they want them and let me tell
you I watch a lot of Star Trek and even
I couldn't follow this how the hell are
kids supposed to comprehend it even the
layout of the scenes don't even make
sense like the aliens finally come and
everybody sees them and they're like oh
my god life on a different planet and
then Zenon still being punished and
she's trying to tell him what's going on
and they're like where's your proof what
do you mean where's your proof the
aliens were just there how can you still
not believe her but then they do it
again yeah the aliens just come by and
flash things and didn't we just see this
why was there that little scene of her
getting balled out Oh what is this oh
the annoying girl can finally stand up
for her you could have had that an
earlier scene and truth be told she's so
unlikable I'm still not quite on her
side when she sneaks off with Xena and
she leaves a letter to her father saying
that she's been kidnapped
freaking kidnapped what's wrong with
these people
okay okay so is this a terrible film I
guess not it's just your run-of-the-mill
bad the characters are all morons a lot
of the moments seem recycled the effects
are a little better I'll give it that
but aside from that there's really not
much to it it's fine because this is the
kind of film I assume the first Zenon
would be like you know kinda lame has
aliens and some dumb technology that
makes no sense and lame lines but the
first one kind of surprised me and I
thought it was an okay kids film because
of that I was actually expecting more
out of this one and instead I got what I
suppose I should have been expecting
like I said I'm not gonna act like it's
the worst thing ever but I definitely
wouldn't take this trip to the stars
anytime soon
[Music]
you
look at the Irish is just my kind of
silly its low-budget corny knows it and
has a ton of fun with it the story
centers around a boy named Kyle who
seems to be the luckiest kid in school
he always finds money he makes the
finishing shot on the basketball team
everyone can't believe how things always
go his way but one day at an Irish
festival his lucky medallion is stolen
and suddenly all his luck seems to be
disappearing but not only that a lot of
our strange stuff is going on his mother
starts to talk with an accent he's
getting shorter there's little points on
his ears growing his hair is turning red
and on top of all that his parents
refuse to tell him about his heritage as
you can guess Kyle discovers they's half
leprechaun and the medallion that was
around his neck is actually magic that
was keeping him human the whole time so
the search is on to see who stole the
medallion maybe one of the kids or his
angry grandfather or who knows on the
surface it doesn't seem like there's a
ton you can really do with this story
but they seem to take advantage of it
pretty well not only is there a fair
amount of Irish lore though I don't know
how exactly authentic it is but the
writing has some good lines and clever
ideas and the actors all have good
comedic timing so many of these lines
could easily crash and burn but these
actors are really trying and doing a
good job making a lot of these jokes hit
I mean come on they were smart enough to
cast lassie from psych in there they
must know what they're doing the film
doesn't go quite as far as an idea like
this should probably allow I mean it
would be nice to see more leprechauns
more of the fantasy world and so forth
but for the most part they just keep it
in the real world there's only one part
where they actually travel and even then
it's at night and kind of hard to see
but I get the feeling this was kind of
on a low budget and honestly for the
budget they have some of these effects
are pretty good this is 2001 and for a
Disney Channel TV movie to have effects
that look this good it's actually kind
of impressive
I should also comment that I like the
way the movie is shot I mean it's not
amazing it doesn't try to show off or
anything but a lot of the shots always
have a little bit of motion or an angle
or a visual style to it again it's
nothing visually breathtaking but you
can tell they're constantly trying to
say how can we make this shot look a
little bit more interesting than just
doing a medium shot or a straight-on
shot they do have fun with those
close-ups and tilted angles but they
never go
too far to where it's distracting either
if I did have a problem it's that the
last third slows down a little bit you
almost think the climax is gonna happen
this one place and then suddenly it
changes to a basketball game and yeah
it's a basketball game it's not like
there's a ton of laps you can get there
I mean they try but you know how these
Disney movies go they won't look cool
during the basketball game not exactly
get a lot of laughs but it more than
makes up for it with some out-of-the-box
thinking for example there's a scene
where they're trying to find these
thieves that stole a bunch of gold they
see a rainbow and obviously they say it
must be at the end of that yeah it
doesn't work the way you'd think where a
rainbow lands and gold is just gonna
appear the gold is already there and the
rainbow follows that it's kind of clever
thinking the movie is full of nice
little touches like that that are
exactly nice lappers but still get a
chuckle add on top of that actors they
are legitimately charming I enjoy
watching Plus a story and direction that
didn't have much to work with but still
did its best and get my interest I think
this is a cute little adventure but on
your green hats or whatever other Irish
stereotypes you're fond of and dance
your way in for a viewing
[Music]
it's Jett Jackson the movie based on the
popular Disney Channel show that I
haven't seen one episode of so yeah I'm
kind of going into this a little blind
but I did a little research and here's
what I discovered Jett Jackson is an
actor who plays a super spy called
Silverstone he enjoys that the show is a
big hit but he also just wants to be a
kid again
so the production moves out from LA to
North Carolina where big-time Hollywood
people had to interact with small town
everyday people and thus hilarity ensues
that's about the most I know the movie
pretty much represents there which it
Jackson filming his show going to school
possibly going out on a date but he
discovers he's getting tired of playing
the part someone asked to do another
season he's considering saying no but
things take a surprising turn when
somehow Jett Jackson and summer Stone
switch places that's right
three electors in the fictional world
and the fictional character is in the
real world a super spy have to learn to
blend in as a real kid man the real kid
has to save the world from Michael
Ironside oh how can any production go
wrong with him in it
okay almost on the one hand I think this
is a pretty clever idea I mean we've
always seen stuff with the
fish-out-of-water stories or somebody
switching places but the idea of a
fictional character switching places
with a real-life character and not just
focusing on one but both of their lives
if they tried to blend in is naturally
kind of interesting and a little funny
just as Jett is getting sick of the
character he suddenly becomes the
character just as Silverstone was trying
to stop Chicago from blowing up he fell
finds out he has to deal with people
yelling at him for not doing the show
anymore yeah it turns out the town kind
of depended on the show to create jobs
and tourism and it's actually a detail
most kids films would overlook and both
sides have some good comedy like when
Jett discovers that New York is about to
blow up by the evil bad guy what does he
do it just goes around telling everybody
leave New York leave New York yeah
that'll work
Silverstone also has a hard time playing
the super spy away when he keeps seeing
cast members who were villains in his
world tries to tell the cops and when
they don't do anything he takes matters
into his own hands
his humor says this is it does also take
time to show the trouble both characters
are going through each one trying to
figure out what to do with their future
where they belong high school stuff a
lot kids think about
around this age there's even a prom
scene where they don't show the prom
holy smokes has that ever happened in
Disney history there's a prom and yet
you don't see it occur don't we have to
hear the pop songs or see the girls the
latest dresses and then of a what this
isn't going on Wow I'm kind of
speechless well that's all fine and good
I do have to question though does this
have a lot to do with the original show
now again I even watched the original
show so I don't know but looking at the
summary of it this doesn't seem like
what the show was about it seemed to go
back and forth between showing the
silverstone TV series and Jett Jackson
just living his everyday life when you
suddenly bring the fictional character
to life does that overstep what the
original show was doing I'm not sure if
this is a really clever change of pace
or if it's something that's so different
that a lot of fans wouldn't relate to it
so if you're asking as someone who grew
up with the show I'm not able to give
you an answer I have no idea this is
faithful or not oh does a 30-something
who was forced to watch a Disney Channel
Kids movie I thought it was kind of
clever I liked that's not all jokes and
when there are jokes a lot of them work
I like that the Silverstone show does
look like a lot of fun but you're also
interested in what's going on Jetts life
as well so I think it's clever enough
though I have no idea what fans of the
show would think of it but I think
there's enough smart writing and good
acting to pull it off if you're looking
for a decent Disney Channel movie this
isn't a bad one to check out put on your
backpack and your spy gear and take a
look
[Music]
it's time for more cheesy spookiness
with Halloweentown to a far better
follow up from the last lame movie with
much better acting much better effects
much better visuals does that make it
good well let's not say if you think we
can't take back the Cromwell's are
finally throwing a Halloween party you
didn't even invite over there grandma
this is being done because the mother
has no intention of the kids ever going
back to spooky old Halloween town but
that of course changes when an evil boy
comes into the mix steals the grandma's
magical book and uses it to literally
suck all the color out of Halloweentown
yep all the crazy ghouls and weird
goblins are now being replaced with
normal people
bland attitudes and a black-and-white
landscape to make things worse the boy
which we now find out is the son of the
villain from the last film takes their
grandma once again out of commission
meaning it's up to the kids to figure
out how to set everything right so for
the most part everything is a big
upgrade first of all look at these
effects okay they're not phenomenal but
they're pretty damn good for that time
period the black and white filters are
almost as good as Pleasantville and they
don't just turn everything black and
white there's still hints of color
around so it's not visually
uninteresting to look at and the color
that is and they're really pops a lot
more the acting is also a lot better
unlike the last film where you're
constantly trying to not snicker at how
long where the performances are here I
don't know if they got a new director or
just more time has passed for them to
get used to their roles but everybody
seems much more on track okay they're
not phenomenal performances but they're
not in any way distracting the story
allows for a lot of fun ideas - like did
you know to undo a spell you literally
just save the spell backwards that's
kind of smart and it also leads to some
good problem-solving as they said a word
that apparently reversed the spell so
they know that they say it backwards
that'll be what the spell is something
have to retrace their steps remember
what they said say the words backwards
it's actually kind of neat there's also
a place where all your missing items go
you ever miss the remote or your earring
or something like that this place in
Halloweentown hasn't but the owner got
infected by the spell - so he has
everything clean and now they can find
everything which is against the idea it
has to be lost in order to be found and
yeah
it's kind of creative the world's
themselves look a lot better there's
much more of a visual art design and
it's more colorful and interesting but
the major downside is they don't go to
that many places a lot of the movie is
them just staying in one spot talking to
each other trying to figure out what to
do and because the spell is D monster
rising everybody you don't really get to
see that many monsters either that is
until the end they have this really cool
idea where the bad guy casts the spell
and whatever masks they're wearing at
the Halloween party they become that
creature the monsters become monsters
the vampires become vampires it's really
neat but the problem is this happens in
the climax why didn't this happen in the
middle of the film a lot of these
makeups are very creative and goofy and
fun again why weren't we allowed to see
him more as cheesy as the makeup was in
the first film they were at least
creative and allowed us to see a lot of
them here it's all kind of kept until
the last couple minutes and they're cool
but for a movie called Halloween town I
expect to see a little bit more
Halloween imagery so I guess that is the
one thing the first film has over this
one is that it does have a little bit
more variety in locations and weird
makeup designs and so forth but for
everything else this movie does things a
lot better the ideas are more
interesting the acting is more
interesting the visuals are more
interesting I feel like they got a
bigger budget to work on this but they
still had a lot of time restraints so
they had to move things around and maybe
they only had certain locations for a
certain amount of time and I don't know
maybe not but that's what it feels like
watching it though they're given a lot
more you're still always made aware of
the limitations but for the most part I
think they did the limitations okay at
least better than the last one
would i watch it again no is there
anything really in it for adults not
much but as kids TV movies go I think
it's got enough to be imaginative a
glowing review but a positive one if you
got a kid that's interested just like
Halloween candy it's perfect
junk food
[Music]
let's take a look at cadet Kelly yeah
it's pretty obvious I'm not the target
demographic for this film but for the
target demographic I think this is a
perfectly serviceable little flake an
artsy little free spirit likes to hang
with her divorce mom and dad but gets a
little surprised when she finds out that
her mom is getting remarried to Gary
Cole playing the role of oh my god I
think he's just called sir do we ever
know his real name
let me IMDB Bette oh my god he's just
called sir
anyway as you probably can tell from
that name he takes the military very
seriously so not only does Kelly have to
move away from her school of alternative
learning you know where they sit on
beanbags and can do assignments whenever
they want and you know one of those
super liberal schools and suddenly has
to go to boot camp honestly it's not
made entirely clear why I guess because
the stepdad is there maybe she got in
trouble a lot mom doesn't look like it I
don't know the focus is on Kelly trying
to adept with her drill sergeant Jessica
played by Kim Possible star Kristi
Romano she of course doesn't fit in
claiming that her old school was a lot
different and everybody's too rough way
it's almost like this is military school
or something but through a lot of
goof-ups understandings and
misunderstandings she'll figure out
there really is something to all this
strictness and her mother and stepdad
will also figure out how do it they have
to a changing world I'm a surface this
sounds pretty generic yeah a good chunk
of the time it is but there are little
touches that make it stand out a little
bit more from this kind of story heard a
million times for example I like that
she comes from this really open school
where they do like arts and crafts and
are super gentle that makes a much
better contrast and understanding of why
she doesn't fit in the family dilemma is
also interesting to the father strict
and sometimes says the wrong things but
he's by no means a bad guy he like Kelly
is trying to understand what's the best
route to take in terms of this family
and is totally identifiable I also like
how nobody is 100 percent right or 100
percent wrong Kelly does get in a lot
trouble and she's properly punished for
it resulting in emotional scenes that a
lot of time kind of feel genuine when
Hilary Duff cries it feels like she's
really crying and when the parents look
confused or screwed up
you can tell it means a lot when they
did something wrong there are definitely
problems though and a lot of them center
around the Jessica character Christine
Romano is a very talented actress I just
don't think she was the right pick for
this part this is supposed to be someone
tough controlling and in charge and she
just kind of looks like she's trying to
play a role of someone being tough
controlling and in charge she just kind
of seems snooty and pissed off
not really commanding Authority and I
get it Kelly's supposed to wear her down
and get to her humanity but she just
doesn't feel like a genuinely
intimidating character that needs to be
softened up there's also some strange
issues with Kelly and her hitting on the
same boy and even at the end he doesn't
really choose which one he's gonna go
with and I don't know it's more
uncomfortable than charming and yes by
the way that is ice man or boy yeah like
I said I never really got why she's
going to military school I don't know if
I miss something but I feel like that's
kind of a big decision and should
probably be made very clear why this is
happening seeing how it's the whole
focus of the film but again you could
argue that's not really the film's
intent its intent is trying to show a
girl adapting to this new world and to
its credit making this new world seem
different but also impressive we see
movies like stripes where the goofballs
go to boot camp and all sorts of crazy
things happen and always in that say me
but I like that this film looks like it
legitimately respects the military
there's a lot of impressive marching and
techniques and they look legitimately
disciplined and even cool while doing it
what's that the final number in the
competition I don't know they're
building this up is like a big deal and
they have to work together in order for
this to work and they need passion and
inspiration and they can use ribbons now
and play pop songs and even if that's
true it's edited in such a way that they
play seems twice or speed it up and then
slow it down and that's really cheating
and it looks lame the scenes before
we're so impressive why did you have to
dumb it down like this
no no maybe they didn't have time to
rehearse it well enough so that looked
incredible but I felt like this was a
cheap way out however I do big time give
credit to the ending without giving too
much away not everything wraps up in a
neat little bow I really like it when a
kid's film shows not everything is 100%
happily ever
shit happens you have to deal with it
and you know what you still count your
blessings and look on the bright side I
think that's a better message then
always do your best and everything will
always turn out your way so yeah what I
put this on again know what I check it
out first time probably not but for an
adult who had to sit through this I
think it gets across the right messages
sometimes subtle sometimes too
on-the-nose
cadet Kelly passes with okay
you
[Music]
I have never seen one episode of even
Stephens all I know about is that Shia
LaBeouf is in it and a lot of people
find it annoying well no we have the
Even Stevens movie Shia LaBeouf is in it
and I find it really annoying I have no
idea this is an accurate representation
of what the show was like but if it is
I'm glad I skipped it I can't say like
this is one of the worst comedies I've
ever seen because you know the Wayans
are still working does play of other
comedies that like hurt me and get under
my skin this is just kind of dumb
the story centers around the Stevens
family trying to figure out what they're
gonna do over summer vacation looking
like they're gonna drive each other up
the wall a travel agent played by Tim
Meadows offers them the chance to go to
an exotic island totally free
the Stephens not exactly being the
brightest family agree without asking if
there's a catch of course there is it's
all secretly a reality show a prank show
that secretly focuses on making any
family's life who's on it a living hell
favoring it so it looks like they
destroy a house anger the natives and
thus have to go through several
punishments survive on their own and get
through without murdering each other on
the surface this sounds like a funny
idea
the writers definitely know the more
they can make the characters summer the
funnier it'll be but sadly a lot of it
just has awkward timing weird jokes
annoying sound effects sped up action
weird characters just doing weird things
because it's weird but none of it is
done in a crazy enough way to get a
laugh like in Ren and Stimpy but none of
it is done in a smart enough way like
malcolm in the middle' we just kind of
watch scene after scene of joke after
joke bomb after bomb I guess I can give
it this one a joke misses it doesn't
hurt to sit through it it's just kind of
dull and lame and usually followed by a
bad sound effect I can't really blame
the actors I mean they're doing their
best and sometimes they do get a laugh I
mean these are really good shouters I
mean like every other line is a shout
and by god they do it pretty well but
aside from an occasional giggle here and
there there's not much to it I was kind
of surprised to find that the climax did
get legitimately humorous the sister
goes insane and chases after the brother
all while the reality show people are
watching it trying to figure out if they
can get sued for it on top of that when
they do figure out as a reality show and
try to figure out a way to get them back
that's a pretty funny payoff one that
has a lot of punch lines that just keep
going and going and get funnier and
funnier even the epilogue got funnier
like when Shia LaBeouf is talking to his
sister I feel like the rest of the movie
is trying to have that randomness and
that wild energy and while the energy is
definitely there particularly in the
actors again you can tell the trying
they're all it just doesn't feel like
it's guided in the right direction I was
mostly just sitting there bored out of
my mind thinking of funnier jokes they
could have put in place of it once they
had so do I hate it the same way other
adults hated even Stevens
can't go that far like I said there's
definitely an effort being put in but
it's almost like there's this awareness
that oh we're making this for kids so we
have to make it a little dumber a little
slower put in sound effects and got
annoying music I mean really friggin
annoying music elements like that may
seem minor but they can make a big
difference in getting a laugh or no way
else for me I did get a few laughs but
definitely not enough for me to
recommend it
[Music]
girl you go girl
she terrific did that annoy the
everlasting piss out of you well then
you're really gonna hate Cheetah Girls
the most obnoxious of these Disney
Channel films I've seen so far Jesus
Christ is this film annoying
imagine the Jem and the Holograms movie
mixed with the Mamma Mia movie yeah it's
that bad that manipulative and that
annoying look I tried to give these
Disney Channel movies the benefit of the
doubt they're for kids you got kind of
look at them from a different point of
view but I swear to God I have never
shouted shut up so many times at a
scream in my life it's so your grating
it's so pandering so great okay let's
just see what it's about four girls
named aqua bubbles Chanel and doe yeah
that's the names they go by perform at a
kid's birthday party though you would
never guess it because they just sing to
the floor half the time like there's a
wide-angle lens there and move like
they're being edited and yeah it's
almost like this is trying to be more of
a music video than a coherent story but
whatever Disney kid's fantasy we'll give
him a loli wait bubbles
okay I'm gonna clarify your other day
cuz I think in a Powerpuff girls want to
hear that Galleria
played by Raven wants her band - cheetah
girls to compete in this bee contest
apparently a lot of the winners go on to
get record deals and so on and so forth
when auditioning for the contest held by
this teacher that just seems to like to
quote other songs a record producer just
happened to drop on by saw them perform
and said he wants to make them stars but
her mother says they're not ready
they're just kids she says and shouldn't
get attention this fast even though they
were entering a contest that would get
him that attention to that fast after a
little bit of an argument the mother
finally agrees and the girl go to be
made stars but the big bad music label
doesn't want to represent gee terrific
girl power they just want to do what's
popular and changed their image and
their songs and totally redo everything
but wait that's not the cheetah girl way
apparently this doesn't matter that much
though because Galleria is already
getting a really big ego and thinks
she's in charge of everything
no really like to an unlikable degree
it's kind of amazing how self-centered
and
in the face of all this character can be
this causes the girls to kick her out of
the group and thus she has to sulk and
think about where she went wrong will
the big bad music company get their way
by having the girls wear animal masks
because some chart somewhere said that
was cool
or will the girls get back together to
use their own manipulative marketing to
sucker people ok so you've heard this
story a million times it's bullshit
let's move on to the other problems 50%
of this movie is just giggling
screeching yelling and saying
catchphrases
[Applause]
Oh except for one dramatic scene where a
girl admit she lives in a foster home
and it's actually like a tear-jerking
scene that comes right the hell out of
nowhere
ya don't actually try to be a real movie
about the problems of growing up you
piece of shit right after that Sina goes
into them trying on different clothes
and looking all glamorous and singing
about how they're the real deal there
isn't one iota real about you you are
fake you are manipulative you are
everything you're claiming this big bad
music industry is trying to turn you
into just because before you do a song
you self-righteously shout girl power no
really
they do that now you're talking cheetahs
girl power
who she's standing up for girls
everywhere it's a movement guys a
movement about being the independent
artist when really it's all about
getting attention you are the most
attention hungry little pains and the
asses I ever saw you came to walk on the
street without giggling shouting doing a
dance number and having a crowd circle
around you all applauding cuz Wow wasn't
that amazing oh this just happens all
the time we're just gonna walking down
the street we start dancing and oh we
can't help it if we're incredible yeah
fuck this shit this is all just an
excuse to get a band going which by the
way this was a band I'm very successful
one two so kind of a dumb question but
why the hell didn't you just be a band
why did you have to make this dumbass
movie have you ever seen movies based on
dumb ass bands they're usually really
bad but they come after the band I mean
you can sing you can dance at least in
that way that's probably auto-tune and
edited and such but you know that's the
business I get it kids want their band
and that's clearly what they want here
they want the band they want the girls
they want the singing and the songs but
that's not what we get we get this loud
dumb obnoxious movie trying to make you
think it's about being independent when
really all they want to do is control
you they want control what you buy what
you listen to and yeah I know that's
kind of the business and marketing and
I've been a victim of it too and even
proud of it in some ways but the way
this one has the balls to mock what it
is obviously doing itself and not being
clever about it in fact being lazy about
it
and instead of replacing what could be
challenging commentary which is giggling
and screaming and dumb lines on top of
cliches on top of cliches all wrapped up
in one of the worst and things I've ever
seen in these damn films which yeah
let's talk about that I'll give you a
fair warning I'm going into spoilers but
Jesus Christ who gives a shit if any of
this is spoiled
whatever you've been warned after the
girl split up Galleria loses her dog
yeah it's pretty much her fault and the
dog gets stuck in something and I know
his sewer
someplace he can't get out she calls the
police there's like this big major deal
about it with this crowd all getting
together news groups are there it come
on it's a damn dog stock but of course
the girls see it and rushed down to the
rescue because of course the dog will
only come out if they all sing together
okay this is dumb enough but then the
boyfriend says hey now that the girls
are all together maybe you can make up
and how do they make up for singing of
course and by the way this is not a
musical like in High School Musical
where the songs are worked into the
story no no they were just singing songs
when somebody says sing a song like for
their album or whatever but suddenly she
starts singing to her girls they start
singing back I'm kind of amazed you can
hear each other in the middle of New
York and hey since we got a crowd let's
do a totally choreographed musical
number on the spot how the hell of that
Crowley even Hyrum how the hell would it
be this organized just okay as if this
wasn't dumb and stupid enough they all
go to their contests which appears to be
over and they miss because yeah they
were getting the dog and everything you
see the empty theater people leaving
it's clearly over but wait the teacher
comes out to make an announcement that
the winners wait a minute it's clearly
over there's nobody in the theater what
no why are you announcing the winners
now but screw that it gets dumber the
winners are the Cheetah Girls for that
dance they just did outside even though
they didn't make the competition they
didn't enter they win yeah sorry all the
other groups that worked really hard and
got the sound equipment together and
showed up on time you know stuff that
musicians are supposed to do all your
responsibility doesn't mean shit because
these four little idiots did dance in
the back mainly because one of those
idiots lost her dog and the other idiots
came together to say
we were all idiots you are all idiots
you're idiotic idiot idiots
oh why wasn't this just a band it would
have been fine this is a terrible kid's
film it's insulting it's degrading there
is so little passion or need to actually
give you a story or characters or
meaning it is just an excuse for a
controlled industry to advertise their
band well saying a controlled industry
advertising your band is bad somehow
this one was tough guys it was so hard
to get through you can have your fluff
you can have your junk food but even
junk food has to taste good this just
tastes like a screeching slap in the
face trying to pretend it has a
meaningful message if you grew up with
it great we all know why you watched it
you watched it to hear the songs and see
them dance and find a reason to go see
their concerts okay cool I'm sure their
concerts were fine it's debatable
whether or not this is so manipulative
that it's bad for kids I would actually
kind of make an argument it is but I've
seen kids films I had much worse
messages and done in far worse ways but
as Disney Channel movies go this is the
one to be for hatred I couldn't stand it
I hated every embarrassing humiliating
ear-bleeding moment of it
if you want a better experience buy
their CDs listen to their song that's
what they're meant to be doing but if
you want an actual good kids movie I say
throw this hunk at dead meat to the
Cheetahs
[Laughter]
[Music]
finally a Disney Channel movie based on
a property I'm somewhat familiar with
Kim Possible ass itch in time now let's
just around the age where I wasn't
really watching kids cartoons that much
I was around late high school or early
college well when I saw people like John
DiMaggio Nicole Sullivan and Ricardo
Montalban were attached they said maybe
I should check this out and of the few
compatible shows I saw I found myself
actually enjoying it but then again that
was a long time ago
is it possible years later now that I'm
older I find that Kim Possible isn't as
funny as I remember it well I'm glad to
say no it's not only funny it's even
funnier this is an incredibly funny
character driven energized and just
downright fun film Kim Possible voiced
by christy carlson romano yeah she did a
lot for the Disney Channel didn't she
he's bummed out because her psychic and
dude in distress Ron stoppable
Hokkien I love these names is moving to
Norway he still insists that he can show
up to help with the missions but being
so far away he's constantly showing up
late that of course doesn't help when a
good chunk of Kim Possible's worst
villains band together and say hey we're
gonna take over the world with time
travel they used this ancient monkey
statue that has magic to travel through
time and yeah that's kind of it I'll be
very honest this is not a very story
based movie it's pretty much just the
idea that the bad guys from this show
can travel through time the heroes can
follow and just all the strange and
weird things that come from it they try
to go back to Kim Possible and
kindergarten where they just make fun of
her they then go to her high school
where they try to make fun of her some
more one of the villains steals it for
her own and decides to use it to her own
advantage
all while Ron's naked mole-rat with the
voice of Michael Dorn comes from the
future to warn them of the dangers yeah
it's pretty crazy it's made very obvious
early on that the focus of this movie is
not gonna be telling an emotional or
gripping story it's just having an
excuse to put a bunch of funny scenes
and jokes together but thankfully all
those funny scenes and jokes are driven
entirely by the characters who are all
hilarious resulting in a lot of legit
laugh-out-loud moments watching these
Disney Channel movies I can probably
count on one hand how many times I act
we verbally laughed out loud with this
one though it entered the double digits
this is funny writing done by funny
actors some random actors in fact
Michael Clarke Duncan is in this Kelly
Ripa Dakota Fanning vivica a fox the
list of oddness goes on but they're all
great and they know how to make this
already funny writing be even funnier
this is the kind of comedy that makes me
laugh the most the satire of superhero
secret agent stuff but also while making
fun of the flaws throwing in some
reality but also throwing in some sir
reality that makes it just so crazy and
zany I could listen to the villains in
this movie bicker forever
I love the alliance of convenience I
love that they all legitimately don't
get along but they have to in order for
their evil plans to work and even then
they're always trying to backstab one
another just listen to them argue about
putting a monkey statue in its place
it's hilarious
people Beach will come now Pupkin flimsy
paper possibly beat the raw density of
stone the action is also a lot of fun
there's something about the way it's
animated that's really energized and you
kind of feel every punch every swaying
every dodge it's kind of like the
dialogue where everything is just so
quick and so fast you almost don't have
time to catch up to it and because of
that they try a lot of various jokes
some work some don't but the ones that
don't work are quickly forgotten and
replaced by the ones that do work it's
just so fast and well edited it doesn't
give you a time to remember when there
was a bad joke now almost the people
watching this are probably aware of the
show some might be asking do I have to
be aware of the show or know anything
about it in order to watch the movie for
the most part no it helps if you know
but you can quickly catch on to what
it's about the characters are so well
defined and so funny that you ease up to
them very quickly and like I said the
movies not really focused on any kind of
drama or a story-driven turmoil which I
guess in some respects could be a
turn-off to some people this is kind of
like Big Trouble in Little China or Evil
Dead 2 or even the lego movie it just
kind of exists to have a bunch of jokes
that move really fast are thrown at you
super fast and when you're done you're
left with a lot of really funny moments
and a lot of really funny characters but
not really a heavy way to anything
happened it just kind of goes from one
crazy thing to another crazy thing if
you're on board for the ride it could be
a lot of fun if I absolutely had to
nitpick I say it maybe Kim Possible is a
little bit of a blank slate she doesn't
really have a ton of character but it's
kind of like Superman that's not exactly
the point
kids are supposed to imagine themselves
in the role going on these adventures
and fighting these bad guys and she
doesn't grade has all the one-liners and
is popular while doing it we're
unstoppable at times can have a voice
that's a little grating but mostly his
jokes it bull's-eyes let's be honest
though what this movie clearly likes as
well as the show I'm assuming are the
villains they're weird but funny they're
powerful but they're losers they're in
control but they're always bickering
they steal the show whenever they're on
screen so yeah even if you're a fan of
the show or I've never even heard of it
I'd still recommend this movie if you
haven't seen the show it might take a
little getting used to what's going on
but you'll catch on real quick it's
nothing great like I said the story
isn't really that much to write home
about but it's just fun it's a fun fun
film I found out recently it's the same
people that did the buzz lightyear show
and movie and you know what that was
really funny too I actually really want
to look into these shows I don't know
they're on DVD or if I have to watch
them another way but I say it's worth it
I say there's a lot of talented people
behind this they're creative they're
humorous they have memorable characters
this is certainly a mission yet
definitely want to accept
[Music]
xenon 3 or z3 as the kids call it no I
was not a kid wouldn't this came out and
I still no no kid ever called it this
he's the final and by far the worst in
the epics xenon trilogy the first film
was cheesy for creative and made use
with what it had the second film was a
serious downgrade but definitely tried
to keep the spirit of the first the
third just doesn't seem like he gives a
shit
at all you can feel every moment what an
obvious cash in this is that the first
one wasn't trying to do that either but
it was trying to tell a story first this
feels like it wants to just follow
studio notes and then tell a story yeah
if there's time xenon is staying with
her aunt and uncle trying to pass a
driving exam so that she can enter a
competition to the moon
yep it's one of those comments faced
driving mountain climbing competitions
that as far as I know doesn't really
have a prize of much worth and seeing
how she can't parallel park yet can
somehow win this competition shows that
she's clearly ready but she can't do
this without a cute little kid sidekick
enter obvious ploy for a spinoff Zeena a
movie that never happened this is her
little cousin adopted by the aunt and
uncle and of course happens to be
obsessed with her dresses like her talks
like her and much like this movie is
entirely pointless
yeah you could cut her out from this
flick and you wouldn't miss a thing
it's like looking at dr.evil and mini me
it's just weird and unpleasant but
something seems to be up as some sort of
weird silver does seems to be sabotaging
the other players forcing her in the
lead she of course has no problem with
this and is enjoying her lead when her
friends finally call her out on what
adieu she's been she just shrugs but
things might get complicated when this
handsome boy she has a crush on is
protesting anyone going to the moon
because I don't really know if they
explained it they didn't explain it very
well or clearly but soon Xena doesn't
want any people on the moon either
because the moon spirit yes I am not
even kidding
is the one who's been using the silver
dust to get in contact with her because
she feels she's the only one who can
tell them to leave the moon because she
just doesn't like them oh and she's not
some formless being or some elegant
looking goes no she's just a goth girl
but the moon is a goth girl I have so
many questions
she tells Zenon to kick everybody off
the planet and when she doesn't want to
she forces her to go down on the ground
and throw her up in the air and yeah
she's just kind of a bitch
but Xena for some reason sees her as the
hero and decides to tell everybody to
get off the moon but first she has to
win her friends back by apologizing oh
wait they forgive her without her having
to do a damn thing if you think that's
not enough to show how little this movie
cares remember that rock star from the
other movies he's in this again except
played by totally different actor and
what a shock he's entirely pointless I
think he brings a car that can help
transport them that's it I remember the
movie felt so long and getting itself
going that when I checked how long it
was I found I was only 10 minutes until
the end yeah it was so not interesting
that I assumed the real story hadn't
gotten started yet and by god we were
actually near the end I cared so little
because it feels like the movie cared so
little everything feels like it's there
because producers just look at some
charts saw what was popular and throw it
into this movie remember how in the last
one she discovered aliens freaking
aliens where did they go as bad as the
second one got it at least felt like
something was on the line something
major was going on it just wasn't being
done very well in this one what do I
care if they leave the moon it's just
one loop ain't the ass that's yelling
and screaming and you know what screw
her I want to live on the moon the other
two Zenon movie seemed about exploring
possibilities space travel all that
stuff this is like hey you want to see
this cool idea neither do i by was this
moon spirit even need Zenon she's
constantly grabbing people throwing them
up in the air she can take form whenever
she wants there's this one scene where
the guys like well if this moon spirit
is really bear show us some proof and
sure enough she shows up and starts
flinging people around why could you do
that before why could you talk to these
people before I know it seems stupid
getting upset over Zenon 3 but the first
Zenon 4 as silly as it was actually had
something good in it it felt grounded in
a certain reality a childish one but
still a reality and there was about
characters adapting and learning things
this is just life lessons you learn on
the back of a Happy Meal box
with effects that somehow seem worse
than the first one ah this movie as
crazy as it sounds is surprisingly kind
of forgettable aside from the crazy as
moon spirit which was just so bizarre I
couldn't forget it for the life of me
everything else is kind of just in one
ear and out the other nothing seems
relevant enough to make an impact
it just seems relevant enough for you to
remember that Xena is a thing that
you're supposed to like well seeing how
they never made another one I'm assuming
that kids were starting not to like this
anymore and with writing like this it's
no wonder is it annoyingly bad no is it
Cheetah Girls worthy not even by a
longshot but it's pointless dumb and
lacks any passion that the first one had
or hell even the second one had I'd say
watch it only if you want to finish the
movies off but if not you can lose this
one in any Wormold
[Music]
you might think I've seen a lot the show
proud family based on what I said at the
beginning of my Disney Afternoon review
what's this on the prop family nobody
this is the proud family long around but
the truth is I've never really seen any
of those shows that was more just to
make a joke work I am somewhat aware of
what Pratt family is though if I visited
someone a Henke as I was always a show
that was on at the background so I know
a little bit about it there's a girl
named penny
yeah I don't really know too much else
outside of that the reason I bring this
up is because I'm not exactly an expert
on whether or not the proud family movie
is faithful to the proud family show I
just kind of assumed the show was kind
of like goof troop or suburban antics
mixed with cartoons a meanness but let
me tell you if it's anything like the
film I just saw this must have been one
of the craziest shows out there because
this movie was weird but luckily though
in all the best ways it opens with
probably the strangest mad scientist
I've ever seen in anything he has a nose
that keeps falling off and his master
plan is to create a race of peanut
people yeah peanut people he even has a
little peanut sidekicks
the problem is when he makes these
peanut people they don't last very long
but he comes across the Pratt family
whose father named Oscar is working on a
food preservative that multiplies food
yeah this never comes back again but it
also makes the food taste awful so the
higher-ups don't listen to him got
something I can multiply food and you're
getting graphic just because it tastes
fake um on take that you can work with
it somehow but the mad scientist is
happy because that preservative he can
use to preserve his peanut people so he
sets up a phony contest that he says the
family won and flies them out to his
Island that's going to be a thing in
these Disney Channel movies isn't it but
things of course go loony as Oscar
discovers the mad scientist scheme and
he makes clones of the family the clones
end up going back to their town
accidentally taking the real penny and
the real family is stuck on the island
with clone penny absolutely none of them
are aware that they have the wrong penny
but the real penny actually seems to
like the clone father but is confused
why her mother is suddenly talking like
a gangsta teen
what's the fun one mama after secret
phone and also puzzled why her dad
suddenly has an obsession with hot dogs
and so are we for that matter without
giving anything away the story goes so
insane and so ridiculous that it
actually starts to make sense they
actually do have a reason why the mad
scientist is obsessed with peanuts and
when it's revealed it's so absurd you
can't help but kinda buy it maybe that's
the best way to explain this movie so
crazy that you can't help but enjoy it
Paul the characters are legitimately
charming and likable I especially liked
hearing Tommy Davidson again I don't
think I've seen him since in living
color I remember he had such this great
energy in this fast way of talking it's
great to hear him in the father
character if anyone's moving out here to
Lamb anyone it'll be me hey of course I
would bring you with me honey the
animation ranges from cheap to
impressive to cheaply impressive it's
not like it has a ton of motion but the
still shots that they choose to freeze
on have a real Jones quality tool
they're just great poses and great
expressions even if they're not moving
they feel alive they have these great
designs that really lend themselves to
being bent and twisted and kind of like
a good comic strip or even though
they're frozen you can sense the
movement that led them to that pose it's
actually very cleverly done there's also
kind of a nice connection between penny
and her father they have a bit of a
falling out early on but I like that the
story doesn't necessarily take it in all
the places you think it's gonna take it
oh the cloned dad is gonna be too mean
as she realizes what a good father she
had right actually no she really likes
the cloned dad it takes a really long
time in a long series of circumstances
to make her realize how important her
real band is again it's strange but it's
somehow really works so again is this
movie representative of what the proud
family is about or is it too zany or not
zany enough I'm not really sure all I
can say is I had a lot of fun watching
this movie I liked the crazy story I
liked the adorable characters I don't
like how the animation cuts corners but
in such a creative way a way that
surprisingly looks great it leads to a
lot of great line work bizarre
definitely but also definitely a lot of
[Music]
when I hear the names TN Tamara the
first thing that comes into my head is
the opening of their show Sister Sister
it had these annoying drawings of these
crying babies and this obnoxious theme
song where they shouts is dead and it
was grouped in with usually some bad
gimmicky family shows so like a fair
amount of people I always kind of
associate them with being gimmicky and
annoying but honestly when you watch the
show it's not that bad the two of them
had good comedic timing and they had a
good supportive cast that was funny as
well the only thing that got annoyingly
old outside of the intro is whenever
they would do anything in unison like
say stuff at the same time or gasp at
the same time or squee at the same time
but I have to be honest as family shows
go especially leaning towards kids
entertainment it was fine twitches is
the exact same thing there's some funny
creative stuff on top of some corny and
gimmicky stuff and at the center of it
are these two actresses who have grown
their comedic timing over the years can
even do the dramatic stuff pretty well
and can surprisingly carry a film apart
from again
when they have to do anything in unison
like say go twitches go twitches it's
our birthdays o light sister sister the
movie focuses on the twins being
separated at Birth only to accidentally
bump into each other years later or was
it an accident this bickering couple who
honestly gets more laughs than they
probably should are kind of like their
guardian angels they watch them over the
years make sure they don't get too much
in trouble but they alter their courses
so that they'll eventually meet in a
particularly enjoyable joke where they
have to keep dropping clues to get one
of them in a department store you see
these guardian angels and the girls
themselves it turns out are magical they
had to be kept apart Alice starwars ala
Harry Potter to protect them from the
darkness and especially horrible fact
that you say we have to look at
throughout the majority of the film
thankfully there's a lot of imagination
in other scenes for example despite the
sisters being very similar they both
seem to have their opposite sides like
one enjoys being up during the day and
the air enjoys being up during the night
one is a writer who writes about this
magical world that it turns out is where
they came from and the other is an
artist who thinks she's drawing
self-portraits but somehow she feels
like it's not her on top of that their
magic only seems to work when they're
close to each other hence why one has a
necklace of the Sun and the other has a
necklace of the
little touches like this I guess are
obvious but they're also a lot of fun
they show a connection in both
relationship and ability as well as make
for some great visual storytelling
things get even more complicated though
when their mother finds out they're
alive and obvious not bad guy is gonna
help her find them the fight thing is
for as obvious as some of this dialogue
is these actors really try their
damnedest to pull it off listen to this
incredibly clumsy exposition done almost
perfectly by these two actors who are
really giving their hardest someone has
been protecting them you know they were
killed in the battle that night with
Aaron my husband your brother heroes I
have no doubt but like the girls their
bodies never were found were they that
almost sounded natural even the villain
we look at him and we know he's the bad
guy but look at how charming he is and
how smooth he is you actually kind of
really want to admire him for how
diabolical he can be but I know it's a
Disney Channel movie we're not gonna get
that deep I mean what these two girls
were separated from their parents and
even though they both have stepparents
and one even had a step hair and died
replaced with another step pair and now
she's gonna meet her actual mother come
on they're not gonna address any of this
actually they do one of the twins mother
died three months ago and this other
mother has to take over only to discover
another mother is thrown into the mix
the real mother a good chunk of the
emotions you think would follow
something like this actually are
included she doesn't want to meet the
actual mother because she's lost so many
mothers before and even the stepmother
she has now is feeling betrayed because
she's almost dismissing her and the
acting from everyone impressively pulls
it off
it's never too heavy that feels like a
soap opera but it's not really ignored
either it does add a nice sense of drama
and make the story feel a lot bigger
than honestly it probably has any right
to be I mean sure it has the lane lines
in roll your eyes moments but there's
not as many as you would think in fact a
good chunk of the scenes are supposed to
get laughs do legitimately get laughs I
really love this one scene where the
sister is saying she should be more
aware of her surroundings only to look
right past her sister and see a sale at
a mall look at the way that shot that's
legitimately humorous so yeah for an
idea about sister's sister being witches
that battle evil this is
much better than it probably should be
it's nothing great and there's dumb
moments but for the audience it's aimed
that there's just enough comedic timing
dramatic moments and creativity to make
it pretty good if you just ignore the
gimmicky scenes where they have to say
stuff at the same time you might
actually find yourself having a fair
amount of fun
[Music]
High School Musical the Disney Channel
movie that started a friggin phenomenon
there were two sequels one of them
giving a theatrical release a hit
soundtrack and even the hit stage play
that came from this kids growing up at
the time were obsessed with this and
being adults we of course rolled her
eyes and said out come on stupid lame
corny blah blah blah blah if you see my
review of High School Musical 3 which I
did several Disney Simpers ago you'll
know that I think yeah it is all those
things but it's kind of smart about it
if that makes sense it's kind of like
our generation Saved by the Bell except
that it knows it's this generation Saved
by the Bell does that mean where it all
started as pure corny gold let's take a
look
Troy Gabrielle are two high school kids
that meet at a New Year's party they can
force into singing karaoke together and
of course sound amazing and sure enough
it turns out she's now going to his
school oh lucky lucky they discovered
that they surprisingly liked singing but
uh-oh he's one of the best players on
the basketball team and she's one of the
smartest minds in the science club so
there of course embarrassed when they
think about trying out for the high
school musical just because they want to
but a incredibly bizarre brother and
sister team know as Sharpay and Ryan are
always the center of attention in
theater and thus they want to sabotage
their chances of being stars so they
start telling everybody that they're
trying out for the high school musical
but sure enough everyone starts to get
the idea that maybe they should do what
they really love maybe a skater can
dance maybe a basketball star can make
cookies
oh-hoh the maddening possibilities on
the surface this all seems well stupid
and yeah it is stupid it's a playful
kind of stupid that makes it very
obvious you're not supposed to take it
that seriously there's a whole song all
the kids sing about sticking to the
status quo no high school kid would have
that exact mindset but it's kind of
satirizing that mindset while also being
silly about it it's also nice to see
what's mostly a hodgepodge of cliches
break one or two cliches for example
these stories are usually about the
geeky kid trying to fit in and I like
the idea that these kids are already
popular and they want to do something
that's not very popular simply because
they want to as much as we like to make
fun of characters like this like Oh
being popular is so hard
give me credit that does show their
stress and pressure that applies to
these kind of people to that pressure of
performing that pressure of being what
everybody wants you to be I also like
that the acting teacher is not your
stereotypical inspiring acting teacher
she's actually kind of a bitch she yells
she screams she has really strict rules
it helps break the idea that this movie
has an agenda to get you into musical
theater ironically there's not much
musical theater in it oh not that there
are dance numbers and songs and such but
we don't even know what the high school
musical is about hell then we can
perform the high school musical all we
get up to is the audition part and yeah
when you have characters like this
brother and sister running around who
are just so odd and so in their own
little world you kind of realize those
movies in its own little world too the
one thing that legitimately bothers me
about it is that some of the characters
cheat in order to get what they want
okay we learned our lesson cheating is
wrong you should never force anything
but then the main characters cheat to
make everything right anyone that knows
anything about sports games or
competition or anything knows that this
is really wrong
this really isn't ethically sound but
when you get to the ending and see just
how much everything wraps up literally
in one shot it shows the epilogues of
every character going super super fast
you do realize like the characters in
the movie you're not supposed to take
this stuff that seriously you're
supposed to just have fun with it so
does that mean I like it um actually I
found it a little dull yeah I know right
it sounds like I'm praising the hell out
of it but honestly it's kind of slow
moving I like that deals with high
school issues granted in a very corny
way but I surprisingly could have used a
few more energized musical numbers
because when they're just sitting around
talking it's bad but not good either but
to be fair I'm sure that's because I'm
an adult middle school kids hell even
high school kids I'm sure watch this and
loved it and wanted to be the characters
in this and spin around and look pretty
and I don't know it's not my thing but I
can't say it's bad but guy you've
directed these movies also directed
Newsies which I didn't like I thought
that flamboyant Broadway style didn't
match the world that they were in here
the world definitely embraces it and if
that's your thing I'm sure you'll have
fun
it didn't really grab me but it's not
supposed to grab me it's supposed to
grab kids who wanna sing and dance and
look sparkly and fabulous and maybe have
a thing for your siblings I don't know
if I'm the only one that got a little
uncomfortable sometimes with that I
guess I can see why this took off I mean
there is a lot of talent behind it it's
just not the kind of talent I get into
but for those that do sit back there
surprisingly a fair amount to appreciate
[Music]
okay so if you saw my review of the
first Cheetah Girls you know that I
think it's the worst of these Disney
Channel films I've seen so far so of
course I have to look at Cheetah Girls 2
and well the good news is it's not
nearly as bad why well let's just pick a
random scene here so I tried everything
she won't budge there's a dance camp I
can teach this summer but it's basically
babysitting see what they're doing
they're talking yeah they're not
giggling or streaming or squeeing or
jumping up and down or shouting
cheetalicious are doing a dance number I
don't know where they're actually
shutting the hell up and listening to
one another that makes this film a
million light years beyond the last one
oh thank heaven Lee Jesus but with that
said does it actually make it good no
actually of all the things that makes it
kind of boring now don't get me wrong
and much rather take boring over
whatever the hell the last one was but
it doesn't excuse the fact that it's
still pretty dull as you'd expect the
Cheetah Girls are a big hit but it looks
like one of them has to leave to go to
Barcelona because her mother wants to be
with her hopefully soon fiancee who
lives there the Cheetah Girls find out
of course there's a gigantic music
contest there and decide why the hell
not they'll go to something I'll travel
to see the sights or at least take some
postcards I'm assuming they didn't have
a budget to see all the sights when they
come across cue boys do some fun dance
numbers and even discover another girl
entering the contest at first it looks
like her mother is on board with helping
everybody out but oh no she actually
wants to split the Cheetah Girls up why
because one of the Cheetah Girls can
sing in Spanish and her and her daughter
sound really good together so she just
wants it to be the two of them wait a
minute why doesn't she just join the
group
wouldn't that make a lot more sense hey
do whatever so despite her better
judgment the daughter tries to split the
girls up and at first it seems to work
Galleria gets so fed up that she's
eventually gonna go home but then they
decide no we're all sisters were in it
together and they have the big reunion
song number and everything seems to be
okay all's well that ends well wait a
minute there's still 40 minutes left
what the hell we gotta do with the rest
of that time well the mother tries to
sabotage him again
yeah she sets them up at a club where
they get paid but that unfortunately
means they're professionals and the head
of the contest finds out and
disqualifies them because it's only for
amateurs but it looks like the girl that
speaks Spanish can still sing with the
daughter even though she's part of the
group that was disqualified she accepted
money - why wouldn't this whatever so
they're gonna sing together with the
Cheetah Girls blessings but then wait a
minute the head of the contest figures
out that the mother was the one who set
up the paying gig knowing it was a
paying gig so that somehow gets them
back in what no who cares let's just end
on the inevitable wedding between the
other mother and the Barcelona guy which
focus is very little on them and instead
the Cheetah Girls singing over their
moment yeah really stealing the thunder
from this plot threat at first the
bridesmaids in the background and that
kind of makes sense but it keeps cutting
back to them singing over a pretty
landscape like the wedding is kind of
secondary no no it's gray the emotions
of these two people our egos are too big
that you have to focus on us or at least
that's how it comes across that's how a
lot of it comes across just an excuse
for them to sing and look pretty and do
dance moves and sometimes it's okay like
I really like this one scene where they
sing this barcelonan lullaby and it's in
Spanish and it's really quiet and it's
really nice it's only two girls singing
and yeah that was a nice change of pace
at legit nice moment there's also a
nicely done ballroom dancing scene where
it's only two people dancing there's not
that many special effects or smoke or
lights or distractions it's just these
two people dancing and they do it really
well and the fast editing and camera
movements here unlike the other times
don't get in the way or distract you it
actually emphasizes what a good job
they're doing little scenes like that
aren't bad but for the most part it's
pretty forgettable I think this is
mainly so kids can just watch it and say
Oh aren't I so much like cheetah girl
number three
oh gee - girl number four it's just like
my personality what if I was there and
if that's something your kids like to do
more power to them but for anyone else
it's not nearly as bad as the first but
it's a definite pass
[Music]
Halloweentown hi yeah okay
it's made so many of these movies I'm
surprised there's not a Halloweentown
surfs up or how to cook with
Halloweentown
I mean the possibilities are endless
aren't they the first one I couldn't
really get into aside from the makeup
and the second one I thought was
legitimately enjoyable even though they
were bound to just a few locations the
third one falls somewhere in between it
pretty much just jumps right in there as
we see our favorite family is toying
with the idea of maybe having kids from
Halloween town go to school in the real
world and literally a flash the eldest
daughter who is actually the only
daughter now the youngest one seems to
have just disappeared
Dennis Lee no big loss is in front of
the Halloween Town Council as willing to
put her idea to the test except well her
magic is on the line as well as the
magic of her entire family
oops so the kiss from Halloween town are
in disguise as Canadians yeah for an
exchange there that's really gonna be a
culture shock who are dressed up as
humans and are trying to be shown that
monsters and humans can get along but
unfortunately this evil organization
known as the Knights wants to keep these
two groups separate because they still
think humans are evil not tolerant and
are just gonna be awful for them and as
we discover they're willing to do
anything to keep them apart I'm not
gonna lie when I heard Halloween Town
High the first thing that came in my
head is oh cool a school in Halloween
Town seeing a bunch of ghouls and
monsters learn all sorts of creative
things it's kind of a letdown knowing
not only is it monsters going to the
real world school but it's monsters that
aren't even allowed to be monsters they
have to be in disguise looking like real
kids that's not much fun because of this
we don't really get that much in terms
of visuals and weird makeup and such
every once in a while there's something
cool like marshmellow spiders a bag that
walks and eats people and even the
Halloween kids are allowed to take off
their disguises once in a while and does
it mierda dreamworks trolls totally
ripped us off thankfully though the
movie mostly makes up with this with
some okay rioting and some genuinely
good performances I mean for a Disney
Channel movie I think we know we're not
gonna get anything spectacular here it's
funny seeing these actors who are just
so uncomfortable and awkward in the
first film suddenly seem very natural
and very interested in what there's
as any good actor should be any weird
strange stuff they have to say they
really try their hardest to make sound
like this is just an everyday thing and
even the humans reacting to their odd
ways get a few laughs I especially love
this boy's reaction when all the kids
suddenly disappear into one car why is
none of this surprise B that seems so
believable to me the message is made
pretty clear as the villains once
they're revealed are trying to make a
whole group of people look bad based on
the actions of only a few and I'm not
gonna lie while I'm recording this and
watching the news this message does hold
a lot more relevance now than it
probably did back then it's kind of like
Zootopia what I thought was a little too
obvious and in-your-face sadly it turns
out is very very needed nowadays so I
guess even it's very simple message has
a lot more relevance the only thing that
was starting to get on my nerves a
little bit the performance of the
brother I don't know he's seeming a
little too OneNote to me just always
complaining always whining making fun of
everything don't get me wrong this is
very hard dialogue to make sound likable
it gets even stranger when he starts
dating one of the kids from Halloween
town until he sees what she really looks
like and suddenly he's disgusted it's
given a little bit of a spin we discover
she thinks he's disgusting too it's kind
of an interesting point of view for kids
the gross monster sees us as gross
monsters but in the end when it looks
like they're gonna see past it they
still say that they find each other
gross and they just decided to be
friends what a confusing message so yeah
where there are a lot of possibilities
that should have been taken advantage of
yes are there a lot more creative
elements I should have been here
absolutely but for what it is it kept my
interest I wanted to know what was gonna
happen I want to know how they're gonna
get out of a predicament I enjoy the
monsters point of view as well as the
humans point of view and when they did
have those creative elements there were
a lot of fun I guess if you're curious
to see it just to say you've seen all
the Halloweentown movies it's not bad to
check out it's not gonna take anything
to new levels or anything but that's
totally okay nothing while worthy but
passable enough
[Music]
Kim Possible so the drama is very
appropriately titled because there's
actually not as much comedy and as I
would expect the focus this time around
is still a lot of action but this time
more about changing relationships I
personally prefer the comedy more but
this is still pretty good after a big
action sequence between Kim Drakon and
she go come on a gal of anything that
pays homage to ten Burton's Batman we
discovered that Kim on top of saving the
world is going through some high school
problems the biggest one being who's she
gonna take to the prom in most movies
this would be a really lame subject to
focus on but this time around it's about
asking her best friend Ron is it worth
it are they ready to take the next step
is that even the next step well trying
to figure out where their relationship
is going and no boy arrives to school
who seems identical to Ron except he's
good-looking and let's be honest a
little less annoying Kim thinks maybe
she doesn't have to sacrifice her
friendship with rod but Ron is not too
sure for far to me strange things are
happening like his favorite taco
restaurant is being changed designs for
toys are being stolen by super villains
and yeah maybe he thinks his
relationship with Kim should change -
it's looking more and more like this is
all part of drakken's diabolical plan
which apparently even Chico can't figure
out which is also part of his plan
because if she can't figure it out Kim
won't figure it out
even though let's be honest the plan is
pretty easy to figure out but kids show
got to give a little leeway and speaking
of Lee wait you have to give quite a bit
to this movie when you find out there's
not as much comedy as there usually is
week impossible but to be fair what they
sacrifice it for kind of makes sense the
first film really was not story driven
it was just an excuse to have a bunch of
jokes based on characters this one slows
it down with only two villains this time
only one diabolical plan as well as
pacing an investment that's very much
like well a movie this time it feels
like there's a little bit more weight to
what's going on it's kind of a bigger
story it takes its time it lets the
characters breathe some might find that
as a turn-off as they just want to see
more jokes but seeing healthy thought
this was going to be the last thing Kim
Possible related it actually was until
they got renewed for another season this
somewhat serious tone is not a bad one
to go out on I give them credit that
they actually want to make a movie this
time unlike the
last one which while I enjoy it
immensely even I can't acknowledge it
was just kind of a long episode I'm glad
of this story while predictable is done
in a way why actually enjoy seeing these
characters go through these dilemmas
both Kim and Ron at times act a little
selfish but it's never to a point where
we dislike them it's understandable that
age is understandable that's never to a
point where it feels cliched or forced
it's not the thing where one person is
obviously in love with the other and one
just doesn't see it and they go
over-the-top and all that stupid stuff
they both kind of don't know whether or
not they want to move forward if this is
a relationship that they should be lovey
dovey about or should just stay friends
you legitimately feel the relationship
they've had for years and years but heck
with all that how's the stuff you
usually expect from Kim Possible the
gadgets the action the one-liners for
the most part they step it up but again
in a kind of different way a way that
feels more like a movie this opening
action sequence for example is done much
slower than most of the other action
sequences but that's done so that it
feels larger these backgrounds are about
as simple as they can be but when you
notice how they're positioned and how
they shoot them and how every action
that they have feels like they're
actually going through it it's very
impressively done even the intro is
obviously in omage to James Bond movies
but again they kind of give it that Kim
Possible feel I really like these shows
and movies that can take something that
exists pay homage to it but still kind
of make it its own thing it's kind of
like what Heath Ledger did with the
Joker it's kind of all the Joker's but
it's also his own thing at the same time
I appreciate something that can do that
very smoothly the jokes when they have
them are good there's just not as many
as there usually are we still get dragon
and shego bickering we get Ron obsessing
over something stupid and kin with the
last-minute rescues and great one-liners
and I have to give credit that at least
in the movies again I haven't seen too
much of the show Ron is not just a
sidekick he legitimately helps out and
he helps out in ways that make sense to
his character they never feel forced
I've seen this kind of character so
often turned into a pain in the ass but
he's legitimately helpful okay at times
he could be a little grating but for the
most part I think it works with the
story animation action and characters
all taking on more of a cinematic tone
you get a Kim Possible movie that's
different than
what you'd expect especially comparing
it to the last one but it's still
reasonably well done I think I probably
rather watch the last one for more
laughs but for a final movie this one
gets it pretty good figure out the sitch
and give it a watch
[Music]
good lord how many of these
Halloweentown movies did they make okay
well this is Halloweentown for return to
Halloweentown gin the second would have
been called return to Halloweentown yeah
i guess it doesn't matter kids that
watch these movies obviously want to see
the continuing Adventures of marty piper
as well as her know-it-all brother and
that third sister that still seems to
have just vanished into thin air
this film involves Marnie going to
college a college very similar to
Hogwarts almost rip offing Lisa
it looks like Hogwarts the magic spell
sound like Hogwarts a lot of the
students are looking more wizard and
witch Lee there's a few creative makeups
but for the most part people are human
looking there's even a prophecy that
says a magic student will come along to
shift power and blah blah blah you know
this kind of story
it's uncovering a mystery while still
trying to fit in trying to do the right
thing even though there's peer pressure
from the other side there's evil
students evil teachers but also good
students and good teachers and just when
you think it's all gonna follow the
predictable rulebook at the beginning of
the third act there is time-travel yeah
going back in time to see your magical
ancestor that kind of comes out of
nowhere it's definitely all over the map
but I can't say it's offending by any
means the most interesting thing in
watching these movies is comparing the
acting watching the first film compared
to the last film is really kind of
eye-opening I'm really wondering what
was going on behind the scenes or did
they get different directors or whatever
because the performance is given here as
well as in the last few films was not
the same as the first one it's also kind
of nice to see how much the family
dynamic holds up okay I can't add like
the Pipers are the most interesting
family but at the same time there's
definitely a lot of scenes that show
that they do care about each other
I like the mother checking in via
washing machine yeah it gets kind of
weirdly fun I like the cynical brothers
still trying to keep on top of things I
like the main character trying to blend
in with new friends but it's not all the
cliches you think it necessarily would
be like I said I couldn't predict time
traveling in this but yeah it's a little
hard to shake the Harry Potter feel and
all this especially with the bad guys
constantly talking about the ancient
prophecy that will grant them the
ultimate power
were and they have to cat well was it
again turned the brother into a dog and
hold him hostage so that she can get the
magical device that grants all power and
magic and give it to them but wait if
she has all power and magic couldn't she
do whatever she wants with it and yeah
that's kind of what ends up happening
and I guess that's kind of a spoiler but
if you were in the situation you'd do
the same thing so it's not really much
of a surprise there's one or two
creative things that make it stand out a
little bit but it's not that much the
best way I can describe it is the mother
who yes I know is April in the onshore a
million of you were matching that brings
up before she goes to school that with
great power comes great responsibility
the daughter straight up says you stole
that from spider-man that's kind of the
feel of the entire film you know they're
ripping off a ton of other sources but
you know they're also having innocent
fun with it and yeah like Harry Potter
the best parts of the movies are the
parts that make you feel like a real
school like they talked about this year
is the first year they're letting in
genies and mummies and yeah which is
tiny details like that add a credibility
that make this world almost livable or
at least you want to live in it it's
neat but is it necessary or super
exciting not really but it's not really
terribly written or harmful either it's
just another Halloweentown movie that's
the best way I can put it if you can't
get enough of this series and you want
to see a fourth one this'll do you find
for me it hasn't unpleasantly stayed as
welcome but I can say I'm definitely
ready for Christmas
[Music]
well I finally finished up the high
school musical trilogy with High School
Musical 2 I know that's not the last one
but I actually saw the last one first
the first one second and the second one
last yep
that's in Tyre way out of order so I'll
just jump right into it when I pop this
movie in I'm not gonna lie I was blown
away this opening is amazing probably
the best thing I've seen out of all the
movies first off it has a legitimately
funny intro the kids are all waiting for
high school to end and summer to start
and the clock behind the teacher
literally gets bigger every single time
it cuts back to her that's so clever it
could be a John Hughes joke then the
song singing about summer break starts
and I'm not gonna lie it left me kind of
speechless they must have thrown
everything into this one musical number
look at the dancing look at the movement
look at how they're utilizing everything
around them look at the creativity in
these steps how many things can they do
with a basketball and dancing damn they
find just about everything you can do
with it look at the editing look at the
camerawork look at what a grand scale
this is and on top of that parts of the
film and legitimately good jokes
yeah not jokes like oh it's for kids I
guess I'll laugh no legitimately funny
jokes
I love these yuppie parents they use
their kids as balance the scene
demonstrating how bad kid golfers can be
is downright hilarious
good job killer make the ball fear you I
actually rewind the film to hear that
line again and maybe laugh so hard it's
also the only High School Musical to
show the bloopers and they're pretty
funny too so yeah an unbelievable
opening followed by some real good
laughs and in all around in movie yeah
if you thought this was the one that's
finally gonna win me all the way over
you're tapping to a different tune well
it does have some of the best parts of
any of the movies it's still on par with
say that season of Saved by the Bell
where they all got jobs at a resort over
summer vacation you remember that of
course you know if you're watching this
you're not new 30s summer begins and
everybody just so happens to get a job
at of course a fashionable resort owned
by shar-peis parents shar-pei decides
for the resort's talent show she wants
Zac Efron as her co-host this of course
angers her incestuous brother okay I'm
not the only one who sees this right
tell me somebody else sees this of
course he his
and Gabriela and all his friends want to
be in the talent show - let's repay
thinks there's too many people and tries
to of course sabotage him into only
working with her yeah okay pretty lame
but it is made a little bit more
interesting when her parents seem to be
opening a lot of doors for scholarships
and good schools this makes him more
susceptible to Sharpay and even easier
letting his friends go while doing the
talent show in the grand scheme of
things is not a big deal they do make
kind of a bigger deal that he is sort of
manipulating himself and changing
himself to open doors and he doesn't
know how much to hold on to and how much
to give up this is kind of an
interesting subject to talk about and
sometimes they do treat it very
seriously but the problem is it's dealt
with a lot better in the third one when
all the kids are graduating they're
trying to figure out what to do where to
go what colleges they're gonna be at
splitting up discovering who they want
to be and yeah it's just done better
more realistic more thought-provoking
and this is just the typical you're
letting that girl brainwash you man who
are you I don't know if you are anymore
granted it's done a little bit more
delicately and they don't entirely make
sure pay the villain but the version I
saw is almost two hours and it feels
like it when they try telling jokes and
doing visual humor it works but a lot of
the drama and yeah even a lot of a song
numbers aren't exactly that strong I
feel like they open with too strong of a
punch that first musical number was such
a big deal that nothing in the rest of
the movie could possibly top it so a lot
of it just kind of meanders a good half
of it is then just moping around the
resort and skipping in kitchens okay
we're wine that we got to see that again
can somebody explain what this is and
while nothing in it is certainly bad it
doesn't really all gel together either I
remember kind of looking at my watch
saying man how long is this movie can we
get to the funny stuff again or can you
throw one of them a basketball I don't
know just do something like what you
were doing before but yeah when it gets
to those enjoyably corny scenes they are
enjoyably corny the last med duet that
pops up fe and had me laughing so hard
when it's revealed who he's gonna do the
duet with that i had a pause that i was
laughing so much you just shrug and
lovingly say only the disney channel
would give us something social tea and
like i said that stuff surprisingly
doesn't bother me that's part of the fun
for me it's just when it's slow serious
and been done a million times adding
nothing really new it by no means does
it throughout the entire film but it
does it through a lot that you do kind
of move around in your seat a bit
there's not even a high school musical
in it the first one we don't get to see
the high school musical on this one that
they just write it out of the entire
movie talk about false advertising does
it need to exist no does it really
further the characters that much
not really but again there are some very
impressive very creative and even very
funny scenes I guess if you like the
first one you'll like this one enough
I'd be lying if I said I didn't want to
see some parts again either to laugh or
just admire how well choreographed it is
kind of a mixed bag but that's high
school musical in a nutshell to me get
your dance shoes on and check it out for
yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
it's twitches too spelled with two O's
because clever if you saw my review at
the first film you know that I thought
it was actually kind of well done yeah
for what it is it's a good family
fantasy that has some good laughs and
legitimately good drama and some magical
elements the sequel is pretty much the
same not in the bad way like everything
is on repeat they do throw in a lot of
new stuff heck they actually take out a
lot of the annoying things from the
first one like they very rarely say cute
twitches or do any catchphrases in fact
I can only think of two at the end where
they do that stupid little dance and
then they both go loser oh that's
painful the rest of the film is once
again kind of cheesy but kind of
interesting to our twitches played again
by the Maori sisters find that being
friends is one thing but being sisters
living together is something different
they're snipping at each other more
having disagreements and not always
getting along but at the end of the day
they're still sisters and they still
connect but that comes to a bit of a
head when their mother the real mother
reveals that another evil force is
slowly slipping into their kingdom and
they need their magic to stop it
particularly during an eclipse it seems
that someone or something in the shadow
world is starting to infiltrate the real
world their magic can get rid of it for
good but there's one problem
well most of the people think it's
Thanos the villain from the first film
one of the sisters thinks it's her
father and because we don't see things
from the point of view of the shadowy
monster it very well could be this
creates a rift between the sisters as
well as the rest of the family including
their bickering protectors who have now
decided to get married all throughout
the film at Racal Clues backstories
shadow sneaking around all indicate that
something is up but we don't quite know
what is it the villain is it the father
even if it is the father look at this
portrait of him maybe he's a bad guy too
after all they were related the pacing
and atmosphere in this movie is still
reasonably well done so many times
you'll just see a shadow sneaking in the
background you have no idea is this for
good or for evil and this creates a nice
family dynamic among our heroes in fact
there's even more than that they find
out that not everybody can use magic in
fact is practically outlawed while the
mother sees this as a necessity while
the sisters doesn't and both sides have
very legitimate points it's not
something like Little Mermaid 3 we're
all
music is outlawed and that's obviously
bad here it actually kind of makes sense
the choices that people make and the
arguments they have for their side again
I feel like that strangely the strength
of these movies is that there actually
is kind of a family connection
disagreements don't always mean one is
obviously right and one is obviously
wrong but on top of that there's a ton
of other things that Disney Channel
viewers would like you'd get to see him
go on date you find that one might be a
prince but that turns out he's just
wearing a butler's outfit because he
works in the kitchen there's a boyfriend
who used to date one of the sisters and
now he's dating the other one but this
shadow suddenly possesses him maybe it
seems to be following him there's all
sorts of nice little touches going on
the effects are still pretty bad but
they're at least a little better than
the last one they at least try to go
more cinematic with them sometimes they
work other times they're pretty awkward
but thankfully a lot of it is shot more
cinematically so you're more looking at
the nice sets and cinematography than
you are how bad the effects are yeah for
the most part again they can be really
awkward it's funny because I just had to
watch return to Halloweentown where a
lot of it obviously steals from Harry
Potter here this one steals from Harry
Potter too but it also kind of steals
from Laura the Rings with shadowy
figures and even a ring and a dark
presence trying to take human form and
yeah on the one hand I could shout rip
off it does seem to come back to its own
thing just enough and the elements it
does borrow from Harry Potter and Lord
the ring seem to be good elements that
they're borrowing from like there's a
back story about how the mother and
father met the father want to get the
mother a gift and so she has for a star
and that's exactly what he got her a
star that can fit in her pocket that
seems Harry Potter ask but it's just
different enough to let it pass that
dark presence you always feel watching
you and always seems to be around very
much feels like Sauron for Laura the
Rings but again they add that you don't
know if it's evil and you don't know
what it can do it's almost like it's
similar ideas but the changes they make
are just enough to make it so it's not
really distracting and you're still
invested in the story add some good
one-liners and even some good dramatic
moments and yeah yeah the sequel about
as good as the first one
it still has hammered in moments and
schmaltzy moments
again I think that's kind of expected
for a Disney Channel movie when it wants
to get a small laugh out of you it works
and when it wants to get a little
emotion out of you it works then - I'm
actually kind of surprised I like these
movies as much as I did I doubt I'll
play it again but that's cool i sat down
and watched him once it felt like there
was a lot more to it than just Sister
Sister if they were witches it has its
own universe it has its own identity and
it has more than enough to keep kids
entertained I know it's weird but as
these Disney Channel movies go these
films are surprisingly pretty decent
[Music]
oh my god guys can't Rock is so bad I
know I kind of sound like a giggling
idiot saying that but I'm sorry it's
really hard not to laugh when talking
about this movie it is just so bad okay
it's not a surreal as can of worms or as
annoying as Cheetah Girls but it really
is kind of amazing how they hit every
single possible cliche you could do with
this story where do I even begin I'll
start at the beginning cuz yeah it's
like everything immediately seems
awkward and out of place even from the
start there's this high school girl
named Mitchie who's really excited to go
to Camp Rock but it looks like her
parents aren't able to have her go but
then it turns out they can yeah that's
the opening what was the point of that
she finds out she can't go she mopes for
maybe a minute and then the parents are
so excited they tell her that they can't
go because they're catering there and
she's excited again well I wasn't that
edited out I'll tell you exactly why
because they saw in other movies this
cliche where somebody is sad they can't
go to a place but then happy when they
find out they can even though they don't
really grasp that that goes through a
long time and there's ups and downs
peaks and valleys and arches and stuff
like that no you just need a minute of
this not yet developed character sulking
and then suddenly being happy and that's
pretty much how the rest of the film
works just trying to cram in as many
cliches as possible they can't even
juggle them all you see the Jonas
Brothers oh wait I'm sorry not the Jonas
Brothers a completely different band has
a lead singer who's acting out and
totally forgetting what it means to be
about the music
so his band members drop him off at Camp
Rock to hope he will regain his voice
yeah because a teenybopper pop singer
surrounded by teeth is gonna help him
discover his voice isn't that what he
already gets even the first scene we
have with him and Mitchie at the camp is
just a mix of too many cliches he's
running away from a bunch of girls so he
hides in a bush she suddenly gets an
urge to play in the piano you know be
herself and play her little solo that
she wrote I think the idea is that he's
supposed to hear her music and be
inspired but they don't show anything
like that she's playing and it keeps
back to him but he's not looking up at
her or acting like he's hearing anything
he's just looking at these girls he's
trying to hide from then she disappears
then he goes inside it's like plus
anybody here oh okay so you did hear
what was in there how come nothing on
your face indicated that how come none
of the editing indicated that well no
time to answer that we have to get to
all our incredibly cliched characters
like the popular bully who apparently
runs the camp well how does a teen pop
singer run a camp even the snarky best
friend stereotype is like yeah music
doesn't fly here it's all about the
bling that's why she runs the camp but
it's okay because Michie of course makes
up a lie that her parents are incredibly
popular and presidents of companies and
stuff like that and she's totally been
in a lot of music videos and oh oh well
that lie be revealed somewhere down the
road well again we have no time for that
cliche because we had to get to the
cliche of the Jonas Brother just sitting
alone and saying he doesn't like being a
label he wants to work in his own music
and not this cookie cutter stuff uh news
flash jackass but guys sitting alone on
the beach playing his guitar is also a
label you're a living proof of that
being a Jonas Brother acting out this
cliche but up we have to get to the
cliche of the bully girl throwing food
at another girl but it's okay because
she'll still sabotage her by
interrupting her performance saying that
she saw a snake this okay so got
interrupted the girl can go right back
to play up no she's too mad apparently
she can't keep playing what reality is
this in where the hell are the
counselors there's no order at this
place but apparently that's still not
enough cliche so the bully girl makes it
look like she stole something from her
oh my god this is overload did anybody
have an original thought when making
this but it's tragic too because that
bully girl it turns out her mother as a
pop star and doesn't have time for her
ooh
this film's deep guys so now Mitch he's
a liar and apparently a thief but of
course it'll take some sort of big Jam
concert at the end to make everybody
okay Mitchie her best friend Jonas
brother number three even the bully girl
ends up being a best friend at the end
okay you know what I am sick of this
there need to be
some consequences I'm usually for
forgive and forgetting everything but
this is ridiculous what number Disney
Channel movie is this where they just
kiss and make up at the end totally
forget all the terrible things they've
done and they just allow them to be
friends again I know it's good to be
nice but I'm sorry there's got to be
some goddamn responsibility in this
world oh and by the way and answer to
the first question you were probably
asking when you saw this review the
answer is no the Jonas Brothers cannot
act we have a problem that actually I
don't really have a problem with that we
have a problem with that one word
payback that's two words by god is that
painful this film doesn't have a corny
charm like the high school musicals or
the Twitch's films it's just
manipulative beginning to end nothing
seems real nothing seems interesting
which is a shame because I think the
girl playing the main lead actually
isn't that bad she's got this awkward
smile and okay delivery that I could
totally see working in another film but
here there's nothing she or any of these
cast members can do it's just every
cliche checklist you can imagine but
I'll be honest it's hard to say I didn't
kind of enjoy how bad it was I mean good
lord even the song shock for Jonas
brother number three talking about
cookie cutter pop songs there sure are a
lot of cookie cutter pop songs in this
so yeah I can kind of see people looking
back on this and laughing the same way
we look back on Space Jam and laugh like
it's just so incredibly dominated but if
you're looking for a legitimately good
or charming movie I could easily say get
the rock out of here
[Music]
Wizards of Waverly Place the movie yet
another Disney Channel movie based on a
Disney Channel show that I have never
watched honestly I didn't even though
this is where Selena Gomez came from
once again seeing how I haven't seen the
show I can't really compare to the
original source material but I can say
for a newcomer I actually followed it
surprisingly well and also as a newcomer
I actually didn't see it as that bad my
first initial thought was it was gonna
be another Harry Potter spin-off like
some of these other Disney Channel
movies but that's not really quite the
direction it goes elet play by selena
gomez is part of a family of wizards
that lives on Waverly Place but they
don't stay there long as the mother
decides they need to grow closer
together so the family takes a vacation
but the teens being normal teens are not
having a lot of fun Alex eventually feel
so shut in that she accidentally uses
her powers to make it seem like her mom
and dad never met the snow works the
parents have no idea who each other are
or the kids and they seem like
completely different people when they're
single using their magic you're
responsibly not caring that much about
other people all the usual stuff but it
looks like they only have 48 hours
before reality sets in and the kids
themselves will disappear in fact their
memories already seem to be going but it
just so happens they come across a
half-assed magician who used to be a
wizard
in fact the parrot used to be his
girlfriend who has a secret map to the
stone of dreams a magical device you can
make one wish upon that will come true
so it's Harry Potter / even-steven /
Indiana Jones / Beach vacation that all
these Disney Channel movies seem to like
to go on upon hearing the plot you
wouldn't think very much of the movie
and truth be told its strength is not in
its writing its strength is in its
performances in a lot of these Disney
Channel movies you always kind of feel
like these actors are shoved together
really fast and yet they're supposed to
act like a family like they've known
each other for years and you can't boy
mom I doubt they had much rehearsal and
they have to just go but here because I
think they did have years of being on a
show they really have a camaraderie they
have the one-liners they have the
zingers but they never seem to mean they
seem like the kind a normal family would
make take for example this scene where
the father asked for the wand back
either one come on come on everyone
now wenton down him mimicking him
wouldn't be that funny but because the
performances seem very real it works
that really is the saving grace of this
movie I legitimately like watching these
people nobody seemed out of place no one
was giving an awkward acting job they
all seemed legitimately believable even
something as silly as this magician
talking to his parrot it's so dumb but
by God every minute he's on screen I
believe that parrot is his girlfriend
she sells it as well as Jimmy Stewart
does making believe there's a rabbit in
the room yeah yeah but I know you know
you were sentenced to 50 years in
feathers take the stone first it
disappeared forever you're kind of good
at this they not only work in context of
the comedy but they work in connection
to the other characters I totally buy
every single one of their relationships
and they would act how they're acting
towards one another the only part where
I get a little lost and again maybe this
comes back to having to know the show is
that there's this competition at the end
that they have to go through in order to
become real wizards but it kind of
Springs out of nowhere in that they talk
about a little bit but you don't think
it's gonna be the climax they both have
to try in order to become real wizards
so that they can get the spells to put
everything right and yeah it's pretty
it's neat it's creative but I just don't
think it was fully explained or worked
into the story that great especially
when you find out what saves the day it
almost kind of seems pointless but still
most of the funny moments work it looks
nice it's creative and even some of the
dramatic moments hit bull's eyes and
again that comes from the surprising
believability of these performances does
every joke work no does every line work
no are there awkward moments what Disney
Channel movie doesn't have that but
still at the end of the day I like
watching this family their snarky but
you can tell they love each other and it
doesn't feel manipulative it's the same
way malcolm in the middle' act so mean
to each other at the end of the day you
know they're a unique unit and they
still function as a caring family that's
more than enough for me to say this
ain't half bad
you
[Music]
[Applause]
and just when do you think things can't
get any worse
Camp Rock goddamn - if you saw my first
review of Camp Rock you know I thought
it was a real piece of shit but it was
kind of so bad it's good and it was just
a piece of shit but you know what it
made me laugh how bad it was this one is
definitely on the same level if not more
but what little shred of naivete the
first film head is totally erased here
and it's parading around like it has the
most soul and humanity and it has none
of that absolutely none of that you feel
every manipulative bullshit cookie
cutter moment for what it is it put me
in a bad mood I'm here to bitch about it
okay so once again Mitchie is returning
to Camp Rock she's surprised to find out
though that Camp Rock is now a musical
yeah not like they sit around and sing
songs to perform on stage like in the
first one no literally everybody has a
dance number ready if someone just says
hey I want to sing about something but
suddenly the whole camp joins in and
they're all synchronize and it's like
High School Musical what the first note
wasn't like that so why is this suddenly
like that it's like it's suddenly in the
spider-man movies it turns into a
musical okay that did kind of happen but
people hated that too but the guy who
runs the camp is kind of bummed out
because it just so happens I know the
rock camp opened right across from them
camp star run by his ex band member that
he threw out because he just didn't make
it about the music man and now he's
vowing to destroy Camp Rock at all costs
how do I know this because he literally
announces it to the entire camp chemstar
founded not so coincidentally by my out
to destroy me former band mate
axel Turner what's friggin awkward
enough to tell their entire camp list
but to literally sweeten the deal they
parachutes some mores on the crowd
leading to probably my favorite line
gram crack is why does that make me
laugh so much it's just so clueless and
lifeless
crack is pets everyplace bland
performance in one uninterested line
gram crack is can't start invites camp
rock over to a bonfire which I swear to
God is run by the brother of the guy who
ran Cobra Kai and we asked someone if
they want to perform Mitchie says yes
does one of many bland songs and big
shock they show them up with all these
expensive dance numbers and hey offers
the Camp Rock counselors on the spot to
join their team to which of course they
all go over if there are any Camp Rock
counselors or staff who'd like to make
the switch I'd be more than willing to
double your salary yeah it's this kind
of movie guys even the blonde girl who's
the villain and the first one that they
became friends with at the end she goes
over there Christ didn't I call it when
there's no repercussions this shit just
repeats itself
this means oh no camp Rock has to be
cancelled because they have no
counselors but of course Mitchie her
friends and naturally the Jonas Brothers
all come together to be counselors but
Oh being a counselor is hard as they all
contribute their one personality trait
of being clumsy yeah nobody else has any
other personality traits it's just
clumsiness oh I relate to them now but
when camp Rock goes over to challenge
can't star master Cobra Kai says why
don't we televise the whole thing what
just like that he has connections to
broadcast this to millions of people
they of course agree which pisses off
the guy who owns Camp Rock because he's
like Oh No Camp Rock will close forever
talking about millions of people are
gonna see you even if you lose the phone
ring off the hook you'll get all this
free attention but nope he thinks this
is gonna be the end which forces Mitchie
to work even harder but oh no is she
losing the soul of the music is she
losing the fun of camp Camp star has the
money and moves but do they have the
love do they have the genuine human
spirit no and neither do you you
corporate piece of shit I'm sorry this
really pisses me off
when Disney and the Jonas Brothers are
saying you gotta be more authentic you
gotta be more real and they just go into
this bullshit song sequence with all the
auto-tuning and nothing about it
feels authentic it feels manipulative
and bullshitty is that even a word I
don't care I'm making it a word it's
Paul shitty even Michie in the first
film I said I could see her actually
kind of being a good actress she had
kind of this awkward smile that looked a
little geeky but it's still kind of
charming here that smile never goes away
if anything they like perfected it and
it's on her face 24/7 I just want to rip
that little smile off I see it so much
she seems like a robot they all seem
like robots none of them seem like
actual people but we should listen
because this is the authentic side that
has the heart and soul oh shut the hell
up if anything I actually side what cam
Starr they say they're there to make
people stars and they say it has a lot
of sacrifice and giving things up and
they're right anyone that knows anything
about the entertainment industry will
tell you this if camp rock just wants to
be a little fun camp where you play some
songs and sit around a fire that's fine
but why the hell do you have celebrities
there the Jonas Brothers are at your
camp as soon as you do that it's not
gonna be about just sitting around
singing songs and having fun and maybe
it would come across better if the
people seem like real people but not one
iota of them ever does the only actress
who sometimes seems genuine is the
daughter of Cobra Kai yeah they do a
stupid Romeo and Juliet thing with
star-crossed lovers on each camp and to
her credit when she talks she sounds
like an actual human being you don't see
metaphorical charts and graphs all
around her saying hey this'll hit a
certain demographic or you gotta have
this funny thing happened because
numbers indicate this is where this
stuff happens she sells it like an
actual person everyone else sounds bland
forced and forgettable even the songs
this is a musical and like 90% of them
are entirely pointless you could have
cut them and not miss a thing I don't
know why this movie pissed me off more
than the last one I mean the last one
was really bad too but something about
this one just saying that it understands
like real are real poetry the real human
condition and it so clearly doesn't I
feel like naive kids are gonna look at
this and say I understand what it means
to be an artist I understand being a
musician I understand the sacrifice and
being real and no you don't and neither
does this movie it doesn't even get a
hint of it both art and entertainment
should be taken seriously if you're
saying you're a movie that understands
both
this is your understanding of it then
you're clearly showing your corporate
strings being pulled yeah said enough
this movie sucked by graham crackers
[Music]
it's The Suite Life of Zack & Cody the
movie yet again another movie based on a
show I didn't watch and if this movie is
any indication of what the show is like
I think it's pretty obvious why I did
watch it the suite life starts off by
Rana CLE having nothing to do with
sweets in fact it's actually on a ship
I'll just assume something happened the
show to make that happen actually it's a
little weird seeing how Zack & Cody
aren't technically in the title of this
movie only the suite life is and yet
there's no suite in it so honestly this
entire movie is a complete lie
regardless Zack and Cody are identical
twins but one of them has a problem you
want an internship to get into Yale
which means he can't hang out with his
girlfriend for a bit she gets pissed off
splitting up with him and to make things
worse his smart aleck brother messes up
his internship getting him thrown out
but it looks like the scientist he was
working with has another internship for
him one that involves no surprise twins
so they're both sent to this lab the
experiments on twins to see if they can
create a certain fruit where the more
you eat it the more you can feel each
other's pain grow empathy and eventually
become one mind but wait isn't that a
bad thing well yes it is when we
discover that the scientist actually has
evil plans to turn all twins into one
hive and force them to take over I don't
know the world it's kind of a weird plan
for kind of a weird movie so the biggest
problem with this film is very obvious
it's not funny but I don't think it's
supposed to be funny to me this is funny
to the same crowd that like to say good
burger like little little kids one of
the earliest jokes they have is miss
hearing mammal for camel
[Music]
and if you didn't laugh of that I'm
sorry that's what they think is the best
joke in fact they do it four times in
the film they're not fishies then why
don't they add up the movie is mostly
filled with humor like this and actors
that aren't bad but are good either it's
slow clunky awkward but again I think
it's that way because it's mainly aiming
for a little little children to be
watching it yeah you might be arguing
don't our little kids deserve better and
yeah sure but at the same time there's
nothing really harmful in this I'm not
watching this thinking it's like camp
Rock to where there's actually a bad
message or bad ideas being thrown by
maybe even once in a while gets a little
bit of a giggle like the delivery from
the mad scientist is legitimately
well-timed yeah once in a while the
girlfriends delivery can get a few
laughs everything else is just kind of
what you think would be done with this
concept just kind of slow and not funny
but I'd be lying if I said I couldn't
see an audience of little kids watching
this and having a fun time is there
anything in it for adults no is there
anything really that great for kids in
it no if nobody sees is anyone gonna
miss out on anything
probably not but nothing is gonna be
made worse by saying it either it's like
a sock puppet show there's nothing
really to it but what's there really to
get angry at either it's hitting the
right crowd and not making anything
worse I know that's definitely not a
glowing recommendation but what can I
say this movie didn't leave that big an
impact on me if you like it you're
probably the exact right age group for
it and if you don't you're probably the
exact wrong age group for it I guess I
could be angry and say kids deserve a
lot more but honestly it's just not
worth the effort it's Zack and Cody it's
stupid but it's painless take it for
what it's worth and just be happy it's
not Cheetah Girls have you think that's
the best thing I can say about it you're
right later
[Music]
I've been introduced to a lot of
interesting kid shows over the years
Adventure Time gravity falls demon
universe but somehow Phineas and Ferb
has missed my eye and do you see people
dress up like them at cons and even some
kids weren't t-shirts and stuff but I
really don't have any idea what the show
is about just that people think it's
good it's getting a bit of a following
well after seeing Phineas and Ferb
across the second dimension I can
definitely see why this is definitely a
strange but highly entertaining idea the
plot a show if I read the movie
correctly is that two boys named Phineas
and Ferb don't want wild adventures with
their pet Perry a platypus and yet
somehow have no idea that they're going
on these wild adventures because Perry
keeps his secret identity of a secret
agent a secret their sister Candace
always tries to get him in trouble but
the mother never sees what they're up to
well this time things are a little
different as dr. Duke Perry's arch
nemesis creates a device that can go in
two parallel dimensions where he's
actually incredibly powerful and has
taken over the world
of course when that successful dr. Doo
finds out about the device he wants to
use it to take over even more dimensions
starting with the one Phineas and Ferb
are from but in order to save them perry
has to reveal his secret identity this
creates a rift in their friendship and
they don't know if they can never trust
one another again and things get even
crazier when they meet themselves in the
parallel dimension find they're usually
the opposite and try to utilize their
strengths and their weaknesses to work
together and stop the evil takeover the
best way I can describe this movie is
think impossible meets Rick and Morty
for kids but still a funny Rick and
Morty the humor is very fast very
strange and very visually even though
not all the jokes get a hard lab to keep
throwing them at you so quickly that you
forget the ones you didn't laugh at or
just having so much fun with the ones
you are even though I've never seen an
episode of the show I can quickly figure
out what the running jokes are Perry
never talks for usually doesn't talk
Phineas is optimistically naive and the
parents never figure out what's going on
with the sister getting more and more
angry with that said I do feel there's a
couple of things I would probably enjoy
more if I watched the show for example
in the last third all these other animal
critters show up and I don't really know
who they are but I'm sure they were in
the shows there's also all these strange
robots and inventions that come out of
nowhere and they look so well done
they must have been from this series I'm
assuming every one of these creations
probably had their own episodes and
they're all coming together here which
for a fan will be a really really big
deal Peck peri revealing his joy
identity is a big deal for someone who
hasn't seen the show it's still pretty
entertaining they're nice if not simple
characters living in a very bizarre in
some real world at first I was kind of
thrown off by the animation I don't know
some about the designs are really weird
are they supposed to be shaped like the
first letter other names but in the last
third the action scenes are amazing look
at how quick they are look at how smooth
it is it's just one crazy energized
thing after another crazy energized
thing and it never lets up it just keeps
going and going and going and it's a ton
of fun so yeah I feel like I would like
this movie a lot more if I did watch the
show but at the same time it does
encourage me to go and watch the show it
seems really cute creative and funny all
at the same time definitely something I
wouldn't mind checking out so whether
you're a fan of the show or a complete
newcomer slap on your Fedora for secret
agent craziness
[Music]
let's talk about the descendants ever
since this idea was greenlit everyone's
been sending me Ling's and updates about
what an awful idea this is a Disney
Channel movie about famous animated
Disney villains who have rowdy teenage
kids that go to school
everyone's been going on and on about
just how stupid this is and yeah it's
pretty bad is it the worst of these
Disney Channel movies I've seen no are
there definitely times where there's a
lot of effort put in absolutely but it's
still pretty bad I what you even do it
just comes from an awful idea in a
faraway land Belle and the Beast rule
all the fairy tale kingdoms I guess and
they merge them all together but put all
the Disney villains on this island
that's actually a little bigger than the
good Kingdom that's confusing keeping
them separate but Belle and the Beast
son who's gonna be king soon has a brave
new idea that the offspring of these
villains should be allowed to go to
their school treat it like any other
decent human being these kids include
the son of Carrillo de vil the son of
Jafar the daughter of the Evil Queen and
the daughter of Maleficent and if you're
excited to see the live-action version
of your favorite Disney Villains your
book should invade these are treated
like the Adam West Batman villains if
the last route of dignity was
waterboarded out of them they're barely
even recognizable outside of their
clothes in fact if you had them in
completely different clothes you
probably won't even be able to tell
which villains they were man just when I
thought they couldn't do Maleficent
worse than Angelina Jolie we get this
interpretation the mistress of all evil
one of the greatest Disney villains ever
is now a snorting high-pitched squealing
bad joke cracking twit and the others
are not much better but nevertheless
they see an opportunity when their kids
are invited to go to school among the
good people and they convinced them to
steal the ultimate weapon of power the
magic wand from the fairy godmother who
runs at the school but wouldn't you know
it the longer they stay there the more
they realize they might like being good
oh so much conflict and maybe that's the
biggest surprise about
Descendants is that there is legit
conflict the kids all do a good job
portraying what they're supposed to
portray honestly every actor does I
doubt they told Kathy Najimy to play the
Evil Queen as this dignified evil
villain
no it's Kathy Najimy you got her to be
funny she as well as all the other
actors are giving exactly what's being
asked for it just so happens what's
being asked for is incredibly stupid
half the time they really try to make
the Disney characters look like the
Disney characters you know that's
Maleficent you know that's the Evil
Queen they have the stained glass window
from Beauty and the Beast
even the title descendants has the
Disney D in it but it so obviously
doesn't go with what they're trying to
do here their scenes of the kids train
sweets for the first time cuz they never
had chocolate or good fruit or anything
like that they start getting teary eyed
when they hear how other parents treat
their kids and compare it to their
parents there's a downright
uncomfortable moment when the mother of
Sleeping Beauty totally disregards the
daughter of Maleficent because she
couldn't see her daughter for sixteen
years and it's treated with all
seriousness I okay so got to take this
early seriously maybe you should cut
scenes like this it will help you find a
thing like my waistline like the magic
wand these things clearly don't go
together and I have no idea how this was
supposed to work the only possible way I
could see this may be working is if you
never actually see the villains like you
see the kids but the villains are always
kept in shadow and they're legitimately
intimidating and scary and like your
imagination can fill in how threatening
they are but no they have song and dance
numbers right off of a cheesy Broadway
show this is so clearly not the
maleficent from the original movie but
it's not this other Maleficent you're
trying to create either that's like
really intimidating and destroyed a lot
of lives and everything either she's a
joke she's a punchline but the movie
doesn't always treat it that way the
song and dance numbers are similar at
first they're actually kind of
impressive this is the guy who did the
high school musical film so yeah it's
choreographed really nice the songs at
first are kind of catchy heck even the
emotional ones are done relatively well
much better than Camp Rock or Cheetah
Girls anyway I feel the did him--it
emotion here but then you immediately
take that point oh
when you hear their R&B version of be
our guest god stop stop stop like I said
it's kind of hard to blame the director
or the actors cuz it very much feels
like they're just following orders and
they're doing it as best they can but
the order is a tone confused mess and
just not a good idea like at all they
talk about prejudice and the sins of the
parents that shouldn't be passed down to
the kids and yeah that's something for
older kids to get into it's very
relevant
he's clearly meant for kindergarteners
and half the time that's how it's
portrayed except one is trying to be
portrayed as this really dramatic
musical huh yes so it is really stupid
but I will give credit it's not as
stupid as it could've been
well okay very large chunks are but
there's also a lot of very talented
songwriters choreographers singers
dancers actors it's the right people for
the wrong project it's hard to know who
the audience is supposed to be but
seeing how they made a sequel I guess it
did find an audience and and they liked
it good for them like I said there's
really nothing wrong in it it's just so
stupid if this is the kind of corny
insanity that does it for you I'd be
lying if I said I didn't almost
understand it is fascinating in its
choices but if you're looking for a
movie where all this talent comes
together in a coherent story then you
ain't gonna live happily ever after
[Music]
let's finish up disney semper with
descendants to well if you saw my first
review you know I'm not exactly a big
fan of this big surprise but sometimes
it could be enjoyed in a so bad it's
good kind of way this one is bad in a
very different way a strange way and
that's saying a lot seeing how this is
already a strange movie series is it
better worse it's kind of hard to say on
the surface the plot seems exactly what
you think it would be the descendants
are still living among the do-gooders
but they're completely reformed which is
weird seeing how the opening song is
bragging about how wicked they are and
all the bad things they're doing and
then immediately after it's like that
never happened yeah we're so bad we're
so mean we're outlaws Oh time to act
like the good students that we are what
the hell is the point of that musical
number in fact our Lee character Mel is
kind of getting tired of being so good
for new upper-crust status and now being
in a relationship with Prince Ben gets
her thinking maybe the old wicked days
were better than they thought and
speaking of which see which that is the
daughter of Ursula named uma is pissed
off at her and her villain friends are
still stuck on the evil Island while all
the other goody two-shoes get to live in
harmony so she has a plan to trick mal
into handing over the fairy godmothers
magic wand to get him off forever when
the descendants tried to stop this big
kidnap Ben and hold him hostage unless
they turn the wand over it's a thrilling
fight / dance / wrap off resulting in a
colorful climax where the descendents
save the day well there it is nothing
special but wait a minute there's still
a half hour left but that's a perfect
place to stop why are you still going
you defeated the villain save the guy
went back home what else is there to do
well yeah this is where the movie gets a
little stranger than usual a good chunk
of the movie is just sitting around and
talking not necessarily bad stuff
talking about emotions where you belong
all sorts of teen angst but Souza's the
movie's over isn't it an hour and a half
that's a decent run time you defeated
the fellow why are we still going this
build up eventually results in another
climax one not nearly as good as the
first one and kind
disjointed even the message is kind of
all over the place it's about not
judging a book by it's cover but then
this one person seems evil but then
they're not then they are evil again and
there's some really bad effects and even
then they don't really utilize that
because they just kind of talk it out
again even though it's promising
something big and even that's kind of a
half-ass resolution but who cares we
have a dance scene at the end that's all
that seems to matter what the hell did I
just watch this movie is all over the
map and I'd be lying if I said it was
worth getting angry at because it's
descendants - I didn't even get that
much into the first one the elements
that work in it are the same elements
that worked in the first one the dance
sequences are really good the sets and
costumes are colorful and again you got
to give credit to a dumb idea actually
taking time to analyze the characters
having them talk having them actually
discuss their problems and the good
problems like I said figuring out your
emotions where you belong all sorts of
teen stuff but that's not especially
riveting because these kids still have
to be marketable they still have to be
pretty they still have to be just blank
enough for you to insert yourself into
their role you're the good-looking
dancer you're the one going through
troubles you're the one that has the boy
or girl that has the hots for you and
because of this the actors are not
really allowed to explore what they can
do with the characters so yeah on the
one hand there's not as many bad things
as the first one there's no villain
sitting around in a room acting like an
old folks home or anything like that but
at the same time why even have it
connected to the Disney Villains it
seems like there's no point the Disney
villains are some of the great cinematic
characters and to not really make that
much of a connection to them just has me
asking why'd you do it to begin with so
is it good no but again like the other
one it's pretty heartless I can see kids
watching it and enjoying it and there's
nothing really bad in it for them and
there are surprisingly attempts at good
ideas in there like I said trying to
have character development a good
dancing and so forth but the majority of
it is pretty dull if you weren't a fan
of the first one this one's definitely
not gonna sway you it's not wave your
fists anger inducing but it doesn't
leave an impact either which some would
say could be worse if you liked the
first one you'll probably like this one
fine if not then just leave bad enough
then that's about it for this year's
Disney cember I thought
now link it's like getting Disney cember
there were some good ones and there were
some bad ones the good ones weren't
amazing or mind-blowing but they were
very enjoyable and the bad ones yeah
they were bad nevertheless it is neat to
see a series of movies that different
generation grew up with it's kind of
interesting to see what people younger
than me made popular and if what they
made popular still holds up I'm happy to
see that some of them do it's nice to
know that when a series of movies is
trying to be manipulative it can be
manipulative in the right way it can
teach good lessons it can open up the
imagination it can teach kids about
character and story it just also happens
to be selling toys and clothes and
soundtracks and so I have a lot of fun
this Disney cember and I hope you did
too hopefully I'll see you next year and
until then keep that Disney imagination
sorry
[Music]
you